那个过去的两周大家休息的怎么样
我是终于又可以得一个星期的假期
然后可以出去玩一玩
然后那个现在又被拉回来
开始给大家上我们的games104
那么在开始课程之前的话呢
首先给大家那个反馈一下
我们社区女同学们的那个各种声音
首先的话很多同学说
我们现在第二节课的作业
和第三节课的作业还来不及做
比如说第二节课的作业是什么
大家记得吗
就是我们那个啊用LUT去做各种各样
后期的效果对吧
我们还做出那个叫什么那个
那个那个叫音节模式的视觉效果
然后呢第三节课的话呢是有动画
作为一个最简单的动画的混合
实现人走走向跑
然后呢还有一个简单的control效果
那么就是说课程组同学们商量了一下的话呢
因为考虑到每个同学进入我的课程的时间
有先有后
然后呢还有一些可能有些东西很难
所以我们把整个提交时间统一到啊
下个月的月底就是8月31号
这样的话和我们第四节课的作业的话一起来收
这样给同学们更多的时间去准备
而且大家如果觉得很难的话
你也不用所有的作业都做
你可以选择你选你觉得能上手的作业可以做
因为很少有人能写全部的游戏引擎对吧
你每个东西的专家也实在是太厉害了
所以说哎我是做rendering的
我是做动画的对吧
你可以选一个自己感兴趣的题材去做
那么另外一个的话呢
就是哎这个是大家反映比较多的一个问题啊
就是我们作业的提交好像老是失败
然后呢
我今天才跟我们那个课程组的小伙伴一起
在在商量
然后现在我们猜测的主要的原因
就是那个在那个games的课程提交网站
因为那个不是我们课程组做的是games课程组
games课程做的那个网站
当大家提交完自己的作业的时候呢
还要单独再去点一下那个提交按钮
所以很多同学是上载完附件
但是呢就没有去点那个小按钮
导致这个作业提交就失败了
然后呃后来我们想了一个办法
就是在我们的课程的那个官网上
又写了一个文档
在那文档的第九页的话呢
就是专门教大家怎么去提交作业的那个地方
我们告诉大家注意这件事情
所以同学们如果还有什么作业提交的问题的话
也及时跟我们课程组联系
然后我们课程组的小姐姐真的很好
她那个大家好多同学提交失败的朋友
把通过微信传给他之后
他帮大家一一的就提交上来了
所以的话
哎
我觉得这里面真的要给我们科室的小小姐姐们
小伙伴们点个赞
然后所以大家如果课程提交作业
提交还有任何困难的话
就及时跟我们联系
反正我们会尽我们所能给大家提供帮助
那么最后一个同学们也问我们一些问题了
这些问题我觉得蛮好玩的
就比如说有同学问我们说
哎我们的pick a引擎要不要做这个scripting
脚本系统
这个这个东西其实呢是我们这节课要讲的
就这节课我们讲那个game play会讲脚本系统
那其实游戏引擎接入脚本系统还是蛮复杂的
就是包括啊他你是怎么去架构接口
怎么去设计
包括你是不是要实现一个
就是比如像graph这样的visual scripting
那这件事情
其实目前的话
就整个课程组会很专注的把课程准备好
就像大家跟大家汇报过
就是说实际上我们写这个课件
是非常非常压力很大的
因为我们没有任何参考资料
所以每节课都要临时现写现编
然后确定提纲
所以这是个巨大的工作量
然后我们最近连开发任务都受了一些影响
那所以的话呢
我觉得可能在9月份课程结束之前的话
我们会专注于把课程打造好
同时和大家一起把PUI引擎本身的一些问题
功能做完善
可能是等我们90月份这个基础课程做完之后
我们会和大家一起商量
如果同学们有兴趣的话
要么我们课程组来写
要么我们和社区的小伙伴一起来写
看给我们的这个皮UI引擎设计脚本系统
但同学们提的这个问题是对的
就是说如果真的要做一个好的游戏引擎的话
那一定是要有脚本系统的
否则的话它很难去做它的扩展性
那么另外有同学也在问我们说
诶那个为什么皮克AI引擎用的是c make up for x Mac
那个实话实说
我自己没有用x Mac
然后呢我今天还专门向我们的小伙伴们请教
我说x max是什么东西啊
然后那个他们给我看了一下
然后我说哦原来是这样的
好像Mac确实是比c Mac简单一点
那但是呢当时我们为什么选用c make呢
就是说实际上课程组觉得
c Mac是现在开源社区里面应该来讲是最popular的
就是说最大家广泛接受的一个build的工具
那么它本身的话宫内比较完善
也比较强大
而且支撑的文档也足够多
确实当时我们在做皮卡小引擎的时候
就有一个小小的野心
就是我们一上来就想跨平台
所以一上来就选了一个最标准的一个解
但是呢其实未来如果同学们有兴趣的话
大家有人说哎我要做个更简单的AI Mac版本的话
如果有这个想法的话
我觉得我们也会帮助大家支持大家来做这个事
但目前的话呢就是说我们会先集中精力
把一个版本搞好
因为就算c Mac的话
很多同学理解起来啊
学习起来还需要花一点点时间
那么如果大家觉得有问题的话
c Mac其实有官方的网站呢
大家可以去查一下
如果大家找不到那个网址的话
我们到时候会在微信上把这个网址给大家
就是c Mac在哪查找他的资料
那最后呢有同学也在问我们说诶
为什么这个小引擎每一次都没改代码
但每一次编译都要重新编译一下
这个其实是我们目前也是我认为小引擎
我们还有很多事情要做的地方
因为虽然一行代码没有改
但是呢我们不是有那个反射系统吗
就是他每一次编译的时候
首先会调那个反射的compiler
他会首先渲染出很多的这个generate code
那这个code的话
你会编译器当成一个脏code
他又开始重新编译了这个地方
其实我们未来是可以优化的
就是如果你的这个数据的
就是schema的定义没有改的话
我们可以不触发变异
但这个写起来讲起来很简单
写下来需要很多的处理和编译的处理的
这里面需要花一点点时间
所以其实就这样
大家也能意识到就是一个大型引擎
它就挺复杂的
有的时候叫自己要做自己的预编译
然后呢这个预编译本身呢
它的比如说怎么样实现incremental compiling啊
实际上是比较复杂
我记得以前我在做那个就是hero引擎的时候
我们当时最痛苦的一件事情是
我们那个引擎编译一下
大概要花掉呃半个小时左右
然后呢
后来我们专门找了一个一个一个很厉害的
技术的老哥
大概花了有一年的时间
终于把我们的编译时间从半个小时
减到了10分钟
实际上你会发现就在写这个引擎的时候
有很多的include对吧
这个include1大堆的类
那结果有些文件啊
你基本上一编译的时候
会被编译几百甚至上千次
就会导致整个编译速度特别的慢
所以其实当引擎做到最后的时候
当你面对几百万行代码到上千万行代码的时候
如何能够实现分布式的IMPLEMENTAL的编译
实际上是个很重要的工程问题
否则的话整个引擎开发组的话
大家每天可能有一半的时间在等编编译了
那个过程是怎么说呢
既可以划水
很快乐
但同时又会觉得很痛苦
太无聊了对吧
所以说同学们问的这几个问题
我觉得都蛮有意思的
所以我在这里也给大家做一些我们的回答好
那今天跟大家的社区互动的部分就到这了
接下来我们就开始我们今天课程的正题了
今天课程讲什么呢
讲这个game play
game play这个翻译成中文叫什么呢
我我想了半天啊
我其实脑子我今天上课之前
我都不知道game play中应该怎么说
后来我想了想
应该叫玩法系统对吧
这个听上去翻译起来还是有点信达雅的
这个小小的给自己自夸一下
然后这个玩法系统其实是个很庞杂的
很庞杂的系统了
就真的是你想到游戏里面几乎都almost everything
它都叫玩法系统哦
所以这一节课准备起来
我们的那个团队真的是觉得头疼肚子疼
就是该讲啥呢
好像这个玩法系统有一部分好像在render也讲过
好像有些东西在物理也讲过对吧
有些东西在其他地方都讲过
那到底什么东西属于玩法系统呢
然后我们花了很长时间
把这个玩法系统分成了两大块
第一大块呢大家可能也比较熟悉了
就是玩法系统的基础
我们会讲A真正更详细的event系统是怎么驱动的
就是整个这个世界里这些game object互相怎么去通讯
怎么去互动对吧
这是做玩法的基础
然后呢
诶你怎么去用scripting写你各种各样的玩法规则
对不对
比如说打砍一刀上去
这个血量到底怎么扣对吧
这些东西都属于玩法系统
那这东西也是属于那个scripting系统
一个重要发挥的地方
那还有大名鼎鼎的
就是可视化的这种挂那个script系统
比如说像大名鼎鼎的BLUPIN的蓝图系统
那这里面的话我们可以去讲
然后最后呢会给大家讲
这个也是非常这个这个如雷贯耳的
叫著名的3C系统
如果大家同学们那个稍微浅强一点
游戏的设计的话
都知道啊
要做一个好游戏
做一个好的动作游戏对吧
你一定要理解什么叫3C啊
3C是什么呢
Character control and camera
就是角色控制已相机
那3C系统到底是什么
今天给大家做一个简单的科普
那这些就是杂七杂八东西
讲完的话
基本上就是玩法系统的一个骨架了
但其实玩家系统里面有很多的细节啊
我们今课程上是没有办法跟大家一一展开的
那么这节课呢我们这就这个玩法系统
我们是准备了两节课嘛
那另外一个第二节课的话
哎只讲一件事
就是AI对人工智能怎么样
AI还是比较霸气吧
就我连提纲都写不出来
我就觉得我用了我蛮喜欢的
斯皮尔伯格的那部电影就是AI
大家如果没没有看过的话
一定要看亚洲眼
因为他非常的有深刻
他就讲了一个小机器人
小男孩
每天想着自己能变成一个真实的real boy
也就是一个真实的男孩的故事是吧
那其实的话那个就是我我哎呀这个跑题了
我在想我以前看那个AI那个电影的时候
后来我玩那个底特律变人的时候
我记得我就一下子戳中了我的灵魂共鸣对吧
我就觉得哇
很能理解这些机器人为什么要变成人
那么其实AI系统的话呢
讲起来就有很多很有意思的东西
而且呢你说讲的很浅
也可以讲的很深也可以
所以我们想想专门做一节课
跟大家好好的去玩玩一下AI系统
所以说整个我们的玩法系统就分成这两趴
那么大家的话呢可以根据自己的喜欢对吧
你如果很感兴趣AI
你可以跳过这节课不听的
但是相信我
你如果只听AI了
你这个玩游戏玩法一定做不出来
为什么你没有前面的这些系统的支撑的话
光有个AI这个游戏也是跑不起来了
所以此处给你们挖一个小坑好
那我们就回到今天我们课程的主题了
那我们就基础的玩法系统是怎么来的
首先玩法系统呢
实际上啊大家觉得做一个游戏一定要玩吧系统
但文化系统其实挺难做的
为什么呢
他的第一个挑战就是说它实际上就是叫设计师
动动嘴
程序员跑断腿
因为一个玩法
它实际上会和游戏里面的各个系统都会打交道
比如说对吧
我们这个这个这个就是武林至尊对吧
可那个我们的卡圣人
他们做的这种动作和打击感
那简直是这个
其实我很期待这款产品
我今天一直在问说这游戏今天上线了没有
他们告诉我没上线
哎呀我我我就只能默默的等待了对吧
因为我是他的这个铁粉
那么好
那其实像我们的这个就是说这种一个动
很有动作打击感的这样一个游戏的话
你要做他什么
你首先要跟动画系统起作用嘛
对不对
动画系统呢你还要跟特效系统对
打击感的核心是什么
特效嘛
对不对
还有什么呢
生效对吧
你一定要跟some effect起作用
你还跟那个control控制的那个那个那个
无论是手柄还是鼠标键盘都要起作用
对不对
还有各种UI的提示对吧
double kill什么暴击对吧
这种东西它它在屏幕上啪啪啪弹出来
那么还有什么呢
还有大家著名大名
大名鼎鼎的叫动作感的那个要素叫卡针
叫打击针
你要把那个画面啪啪啪整个卡住
所以你还要跟渲染系统起作用
所以其实我作为一个非常简单的一个玩法
就是一个有打击感的东西
实际上你作为games play的engineer
就作为玩法工程师的话
他虽然这些每个系统都不需要他写作animation
animation系统的工程师对吧
做sound effect系统
有sound effect系统工程师
做这个UI系统
UI系统工程师等等等等等
但是我们的game play的engineer
他要和所有人在一起talk
然后呢他才能够满足我们设计师的需求
否则的话啊他就是做不出来
所以说其实啊game plan engineer
他很多时候都是个杂学家
就是什么东西都得懂那么一点点
这是做game play的第一个挑战
那么做game play的第二个挑战是什么呢
就是说其实啊在游戏里面
game play真的是多种多样的
我们不要说不同的游戏类型啊对吧
你一会儿有RTS
一会儿又是这个FPS
一会儿又是ACT游戏对吧
就算在同一个游戏呢
比如说大家去玩巫师的时候对吧
核心战斗是这个样子的
我看见怪我就砍我卡斯特
我的魔法
我的各种技能特效打的砰砰砰
打到怪物上很有打击感
对不对
但是你玩昆特牌的时候
你发现啊
这又是一个很好玩的一个游戏
我一直认为巫师是一个被动作耽误了的一个
昆特牌游戏对吧
那很多人都觉得昆特牌比这个巫师本体好玩
当然这个有点夸张了
但是我们再想象一下
就是如果我们想做一个像
比如说像荒野大镖客这样的游戏
你想这个事件里面你能做的丰富的玩法
机制类型有多少
比如大家如果玩网游的话
那真的网游里面是什么什么能搞
比如说你在里面可以抛绣球
可以踢足球
可以这个大家一起玩吃鸡
还有大家还可以一起去什么打牌
下五子棋
还有什么还可以参加这个什么啊
科举你还可以考状元
所以这些所有的东西我们都要统称玩法啊
这些玩法的话呢
哎我们很多时候要把它做进一个游戏里面去
音响
这个时候玩法系统的架构
包括玩法系统的这种叫做可扩展性
其实要求是非常高的
这也是玩法系统一个很挑战的一个东西
那么第三个的话呢就是玩法系统
我们认为比较有意思的东西是什么呢
叫快速迭代
大家知道这个这个这个four night堡垒之夜很厉害
对不对
但是不知道堡垒之夜最开始的时候
他不是现在这个吃鸡模式
它是一个mo对吧
当时最早EPIC是想把它做成一个
就末世题材的生存类mo
但是呢有一天这个就是我们的team同学
叫team smiai
就是那个EPIC的老大
他觉得哎好像这种重度的mm好像没有什么市场
我们还不如做个轻量的
以吃鸡为题材的这样的一个游戏对吧
就出现了PUB啊
不是PVG啊
就是那个for night对吧
battle royal这样的一个一个模式
好
从老大下定决心到团队搞出来
给的时间多久呢
两个月
所以说其实你在做game play的时候
你想这么大一个游戏两个月就搞定了
真的就两个月搞定
为什么就game play系统还有一个很大的特点
他和我们做rendering
做animation不一样
比如说rendering
我一个feature对吧
像我之前讲的叫sky啊
讲的那些
比如说TURING啊
一个系统从决定要干到他做下去
很多时候是半年以上
甚至有的系统要做一年以上
因为它的算法很复杂嘛
你就一步无数的敌它迭代调整
然后呢跟美术去磨整个流程
所以这个过程是一个很怎么说呢
很漫长
很专注
但是呢又是相对稳定的过程
但是gap edge near他面对的情况是什么
前两天设计师跟你讲说
哎我们要做这个玩法好
大家一起做出来了
诶
出来玩了两天之后
大家觉得不对劲了
好马上要改
我有了一个新的想法
好两天之后又要变出一个新的玩法
所以其实game play它是整个游戏系统里面
迭代速度最快的一趴
所以当我们设计这样的一个game play系统的时候
我们在引擎侧一定要支持它快速迭代的功能
所以说回想一下
就是说我们要做game play怎么样
第一它是要有能力和各个系统进行talk对吧
它是能够把各个系统的AI功能全部能调用
第二个是什么呢
就是说哎它具有很强的玩法扩展性对吧
你在这里面可以玩一个非常叙事性的内容
也可以玩一个打击感对抗性很强的内容
对不对
也可以玩一些哎比较有意思的探索性的内容
这都是跟UI系统我们要支持支撑的
第三个就是这么多乱七八糟的玩法诶
都是要求相对快的速度
可能是比如说几几天几周对吧
一般很少GAMEPLAY会做几个月以上
那是非常难的那种games play
但是那种game play都是迭代一个几个月以上的
game play的研发都是拆成很多很多的那个小的
这个sprint就是小的一个突击
我们把它做出来
然后再看它的效果好坏
再去迭代它
所以这其实就是game play系统的一个要求
就是说他就我我我总结一下叫做
就是他就要求第一要砸血
第二个什么呢
要价格便宜
量又足对吧
这才能支撑我们一个丰富的游戏体验
那么怎么去做game play呢
那首先的话回想一下
我记得我们在第二节课跟大家讲说
哎游戏系统怎么搭的
其实我一直在想说
如果你想理解游戏引擎
那个第二节课听完之后
你就可以出去跟人吹了
我大概知道游戏引擎咱们加了
因为在那节课里面呢
我们就讲到了
说这个游戏世界是有无数的机油object
game object构成的对吧
那game object之间的话呢
其实如果能让他玩起来
首先他们彼此是要能talked的对吧
我一个炸弹能告诉你们说
不好意思
我要炸了你们对吧
我一个坦克发射一个炮弹对吧
我会告诉你们说一只炮弹正在飞来
那么这些game object之间的话呢
我们认为要能talk
但是talk的话
如果你把它写死成我的代码中的话
那是不是就像我们的第二课
第二节课讲的就是说你就是一堆if else if else哇
这个或者是switch case对吧
这样的一个branch的一个循环
那这个代码写到后来肯定不是给人看的
基本上就崩掉了
整个系统都不知道怎么维护了
所以呢在第二节课我们就讲了
就说哎其实你应该用event message的一个机制
就是把所有在这个事件发生的事情
变成一个event或者叫message
其实我自己很多时候很迷乱
虽然我们经常一直叫它event系统
但实际上呢在游戏引擎写的时候
我们会经常把它写成message
好像觉得message很有感觉
我记得我在第二节课讲了
这个男女朋友要分手的那个例子对吧
就是那个你们家门口有个邮箱
互相递那个分手信
其实我觉得message很有感觉
就很有那种物理的实体感
确实就是在游戏世界里面
在每个tick我们的co之间诶
互相给对方写信
然后呢收到信的人
每个人做出自己的响应
这其实就是个最基础的诶
我们对这个世界的互动的一个方法
就相当于我们之间建立了这样的一个通讯协议
那今天的这节课里面我们讲game play系统
那我会稍微讲的细那么一点点
就是说如果你真的想做一个玩法系统
你想做一个能够应对相对复杂的
一个游戏机制的话
我们的引擎测疑问的系统它该怎么去做
那在这里面的话呢
其实我们上升一个相对高的一点高度啊
其实这个模型啊它是一个它的设计范式
叫做publish
Subscribe pattern
就是说发行者和这个注册者
Secreation
就是那个注册者的这个pattern
就相当于就是说有人负责发布信息
另外一群人注册一些信息
就这些信息来的时候我就注册了
就是这个这个叫发行或者订阅吧
中文应该叫订阅
订阅可能更好一点
就相当于是说每个人都出自己的校园小报
但是我喜欢那几个同学的文笔
我就订订阅那几个同学的小报
所以它是这样的一个标准的一个pattern
那在这样的一个pattern里面的话呢
实际上它有几个很重要的元素
第一个就是我扔出去的各种各样的events对吧
各种各样的事件
第二个呢这event需要有一个系统
这个系统叫什么呢
叫event dispatcher
你可以认为它是个物流公司
就是你每天这个你在淘宝上订的东西
那那那个就是商家把东西都发出来了
就是你买的东西
然后呢这个物流公司它其实很强大
大家不要千万不要低估物流啊
物流行业其实是一个技术密度很高的一个行业
但因为他的这些信息的分拣派送
实际上是很在乎效率
而且要进行一些算法的
所以event dispatui它就像物流公司一样
他做好这个信息的分拣派送
然后呢
唉再到我们各个的接收者进行相应的动作
这个我们叫什么叫QUEBEC
所以呢其实在一个poption subscription model
就是发行者和订阅者的这个pattern里面的话
三个key component就是第一个就是消息的定义
你的event definition
然后呢你的所有的哎这种消息来的时候
我该怎么去处理呢
对不对
这个处理的函数我们叫做call back
call back呢
我们在第二节课讲的都很简单
实际上call back呢是有一个注册的过程呢
就是说你得告诉别人说
当有这类消息来了之后
你调我这个动作对吧
这个是要有一个注册关系
注册在这儿了
然后呢
另外一个的话呢
就是我一每一帧会产生几百甚至上千的
各种各样的消息
那这个event这个DISPUI就像物流公司一样的
他要把消息送到各个对应的那个机构那边去
所以这三个要素呢
实际上是我们一般系统的核心好
这里面有什么坑呢
第一个就是event呢
首先你要去定义它
就event definition对吧
那最简单的就是说首先每个一般它有个type
大家能想到最简单的方法是什么
诶
我定义一个枚举类型
就用数字对吧
这枚举类型是字符串
你看起来像磁场
它实际上是一个唯一的标识号
那这个东西呢实际上在系统里面
有的时候在早期引擎的时候呢
是这个程序员自己手打的
我定义了100种不同的event
根据我们的策划的需求
但是你会发现到后来
连even的type都是需要这个交给设计师去创建的
然后呢每个event呢它还有很多很多什么呢
它的它的数据叫event arguments
或者叫有的时候叫payload
就是说产生这个event了
比如说发生了一个爆炸
那你得告诉我说你爆炸的地点在哪里呀对吧
你给我带来的伤害是多少啊
伤害什么类型啊
那这些东西它又变成event的数据好
那最简单的解决方法是什么
如果大家学过面向对象的话
是不是觉得哦这很简单
我知道怎么写对吧
那我就是第一个event的鸡肋对吧
然后呢
其他所有的event都派生自他在这上面的话呢
我会去定义他各自独自的这种数据类型
这个呢其实没有问题的
如果你整个游戏引擎game play都是用C加加写的
或者用某种面向对象语言去写
就是可以的
但是呢就像我前面讲的就是做游戏
它最复杂的情况是什么
90%的情况下
玩法不是由我们程序员决定卡
所以说当我们决定在做一个游戏之前的话
我们基本上不知道这个游戏
会产生多少种类型的这种event
因为很多都是在我们的设计师在研发过程中
他们觉得诶我需要有一个比如说大boss残血之身
那个一半
大boss
马上要切到他的这个这个第二段状态的时候
这样的一个消息对吧
那这个时候不可能你写代码的时候知道了
所以呢诶我们要允许就是设计师去定义
各种各样的event类型
所以呢
这里面我展示了一个荣耀里面的一个定义
定义这个event的数据的方法其实非常简单
就是你去定义A你的event这个inner是什么
当然它会形成一个唯一的引导
这个这个算法其实并不难
然后呢
A你在定义A我需要有哪些不同数据结构
然后用我们前面的方法
大家还记得我们在上节课讲工具的讲过什么诶
讲过代码渲染对吧
现在大家看到这个大家就知道了
我用这个方法其实很容易的
就可以渲染出一个诶引擎的代码
就把这些这些新的这些event类型
把它定义进去了
但因为其实啊我讲的是一个最简单的做法
但实际上大家想想看
如果我这么做的话
是不是要求设计师每改一次这样的event
我的整个引擎的代码需要重新编一遍
这样是不是很麻烦
大家想
对不对
所以实际上呢在真实的游戏设计中的话
我们有一个很重要的能力
就是允许设计师在我的核心引擎代码之外
能够扩展它的event的定义
所以有些event它可能是通过纯数据的方式定义
在我的工具链和我的游戏的game play系统里面去
所以game play他的这个东西很有意思啊
他就是说呃
我觉得在作为引擎做玩法系统的时候
很多我们只是提供一些最基础的工具
但是game play
经常写着写着就写成具体的游戏系统了
那我们在这个设计中的话
就是引擎这个侧要提供的功能是什么呢
就是说你在这个游戏相关的引擎呃
游戏代码中或者游戏相关的数据中
都能去扩张我的gay系统
但这里面怎么做到的
其实讲起来就比较复杂了
我举个简单的例子
比如说像AI里面的话
这个event你可以这样去定义
你用这个可视化的方法去定义
然后呢它实际上还是生成CCR的代码
但是呢它的引擎架构就可以允许说
在这引擎运行时的wrong time
他可以把这一段新编译出来的一个C加代码
当成一个DIAI
我注入进去
那这件事情
他就是花了很多功夫去解决这个问题嘛
但有有的引擎它用什么方法呢
哎我的上层做了一层
比如说其他语言
比如像C12F这样的接口对吧
它很容易动态的挂件和扩展
还有的语言
还有的引擎怎么办呢
哎我用脚本语言对吧
我在脚本里面定义一些event
所以各自都有各自的方法
但是这个东西我就不展开
但是其实光event的定义就是具有一个可扩展性的
event的定义
这件事情其实不简单的
就大家如果真的有兴趣去研究引擎的时候
你会发现这一趴很值得你去设计
而且这个东西呢也关系到我们后面的东西好
那当我们有了这样的一些event之后呢
接下来我们要注册我们的响应函数了
对不对
我们要call back了
那么QUEBEC这个东西呢
其实这个名词很有意思啊
叫回调函数
其实说实话当时我听到这个名字的时候
我就觉得啊这个翻译的这个这个不能怪翻译
翻译
我看到这个英文名
我也觉得叫毁掉
但是我总觉得这玩意像是一个
其实我蛮喜欢他另外一个叫法叫invoke
就是说哎我去激活它
我去这个这个这个就是触发这种感觉
其实我一直觉得回调不是回调
是触发
就相当于我提前准备好了一堆堆的小的
piece of code对吧
一些小的功能模块
你不是回调的
我还是说你把我激活了
但没关系
这个是这个既然游戏行业已经这么
这不仅是我们整个计算机行业都已经这么定了
那我们就follow这个paradise对吧
我们叫做回调函数
但是我更喜欢的叫invoke这个词
就是说当有一个什么消息来了之后
你把我一段处理方法这个激活了就赢过我了
那这个回调函数呢你是需要提前注册好的
就是比如说我收到一个damage的这个event
那我就毁掉一个就damage这个handle对吧
Handler
那我去handle这个AI的事情
比如说我遇到了一个叫做什么
这个这个这个什么color change
或者说我的status change
比如说move on change
或者说reloading这样的一个消息过来之后诶
那我就调动我reloading这个装
重新装弹这样的一个操作
那这个事情也是对的
都很简单诶
有意思的事情就来了
就是说其实啊在这个回调函数里面
有一个特别容易踩的坑是什么呢
就是说你会发现回调函数的注册和它的执行
不是在一起的
这很好理解
对不对
一般来讲我们都是先注册后执行
但是在这个中间间隔里面
其实各种幺蛾子都会发生
这就相当于你跟你朋友约好了
说哎那个等什么时候有空
我们俩一起喝茶对吧
好女朋友说好
我把这个喝茶的这个这个这个这个这个时间点
什么那个预约全部定好了
但是呢到那个礼拜六的时候
你那个朋友可能会发生各种各样很奇怪的事情
对吧
他会突然说我有事好了
你那个手上那一张这个入场券
是不是就等于白买了
其实在我们的引擎里面
最复杂
最容易出问题的
就是说一个对象的生命周期
和它回调函数的安全性
就经常你注册了一个回调函数
如果这个东西我没有设计好的话呢
哎就会导致整个系统就是在那边就会犯错
甚至会导致整个系统的崩塌
为什么
比如说你毁掉了一个东西
它的物体不存在了
这里面举个例子吧
比如说我们注册了一个函数对吧
这个函数呢就专门收这种
就是对我的这个血量有伤害的
这样的一个一个一个处理好
那这个函数呢注册都没有问题
但是如果在下一帧的时候
这个对象他可能已经死亡了
这个对象已经被销毁掉了
诶这时候如果有个手雷在旁边爆炸对吧
这个回调函数你再去调它的时候
它可能就掉到了一个野指针
那这个东西它就会出问题
那大家会说那没关
没关系啊对吧
你的回调
你这个这个对象的回调还是注册在这
如果你对象删除掉我这个回调函数也一并删掉
对不对
这个方法是有没有问题的
有问题没问题
你可以这么做
但实际上的话你会发现
当你一个游戏引擎里面
管理的几千上万个机油对吧
就是游戏object
你又注册了相近
可能是他十倍以上的这样一个call back函数的时候
他的这种管理就会变得非常的复杂
而且很多时候很容易写出bug
那东西怎么办呢
其实这里面其实
就引入了一个很重要的一个概念
这个概念其实大家如果去学习C加11的时候
就学到了诶
我们最早以前讲指针对吧
指针非常简单
就是一段地址嘛
但是呢A在现代C加加语言
其实很多现代语言里面都会引入这个这个pointer
有什么叫weak pointer对吧
还有各种各样的什么reference啊
还有什么各种各样的这个还有什么
我忘了好几个好几种那个reference
他其实都在解决一个问题
就是一个对象的生命周期的问题
有些概念比较复杂
我先在这里面我就讲两个非常简单的概念
就是说第一个就是强引用
什么意思
就是说我的回调函数注册在这儿了
不好意思
你这个对象就不能删除掉
为什么因否则我下次调到了之后
你删除了我怎么办对吧
这个做法呢会保证就是说整个饮用的安全性
但是的话呢它会导致一个问题
就是说有些对象真的应该被销毁了
但是呢因为你有一些函数注册了引用了
我就不能被销毁
那这个做法就会导致系统的内存就会越来越大
越来越大越来越大
所以现在已经很少这么做
但这个这种reference在游戏中有没有用的
其实还是有用的
就是说其实这个词strong reference
我个人觉得呃就是他跟你语义我
我比如像我当时在学引擎的时候
我会把它定义成叫persisted
就是说你拥有它控制权
比如说我一个小的一个房间里面对吧
这个房间里所有的物体
那我对他的关系是个拥有关系
就是包含关系
那好只要我这个房间不要销毁
那我这里面的物体就不能被销毁对吧
随便你物体就算被那个依赖一句怎么样
我都不销毁你
除非我这房间整个offload了
但是呢还有一种reference呢
他就做的诶
相对来讲就没有那么霸道
我们叫做wake reference
什么意思
就是说这个游戏对象唉
我这个回调函数确实要依赖于这个对象
但是呢我你如果要删除
你就真的删除
但是呢当我去调这个reference的时候
其实我只要加额外的一步
就是判断一下你那个物体
这个那个对象有没有被删掉对吧
其实简单来讲
就是说其实大家如果学过那个C加11啊
或者一些其他的
比如像我记得
好像很多smart pointer干的就是这个事儿对吧
就是说你会检验一下
我的这个pointer到底有没有效
比如说我的owner已经没了
那我的pointer就无效了
那么我首先下面所有的处理我都不做了
而且把自己制成无效
这样大家都知道了
那这个做法呢
实际上就会使得肌肉的释放会变得比较的easy
比较高效
那么其实呢我们在游戏世界里面
就是物体之间的引用关系
包括函数call back函数和物体引用关系
两种引用都是非常有用的
比如说经常物体和物体之间
如果像刚才我举的那个例子
就是比如说在游戏中啊
GO期间是可以形成一个嵌套关系的对吧
那么如果我的父物体没有被销毁的话
我的子物体就不能被销毁
那这种就是一种strong reference
我其实表达了一种内存的锁定关系
那么但是呢机油之间
比如说唉我想存一下现在我所有能看见的人
那这种reference的话呢
我们一般就用wake reference
什么意思
就是说这个人我觉得我应该可以看见的
比如说我便利我现在所有能看见的敌人
我选择其中一个去攻击我
如果是下一帧或者前几帧算出来这个值的话
这一帧我决定要发起攻击动作
但那个时候的reference的话呢
我们就用micro
为什么呢
因为也许那个人在你前几帧里面
你觉得好像他还在你面前
对不对
你还想攻击他
但是这个时候那个人其实已经死了
已经GC就是那个garbage collection
已经把它们那个内存释放掉了
那你实际上就可以知道说这个对象已经无效了
所以真在你真实的在写一个游戏引擎的时候
其实strong和weak reference都是非常重要的
一个支撑性的一个功能
而且这个东西的话呢事实上是一定要用对
千万不要用错
那么对于call back function的话呢
其实很多时候我们WAKRAFT用的比较多一点好
这个其实是啊一个非常重要的
就是当我们注册我们的call back函数的时候
特别要注意的一件事情
因为你很多时候会遇到整个环境的不确定性
其实在真实的游戏引擎中特别做玩法的时候
我们的一个游戏对象
有一个游戏对象放在那儿
实际上有几十个系统
用各种不同的逻辑对它进行操作
一会儿让他生
一会儿让他死
所以呢你在任何一个系统里面去应用它的时候
其实你就不能假设那个物体一定是有效的
但是呢你要是做大量的这种判断
诶
你又会让你的这个引擎速度变得很慢
所以这是个很两难的一个问题
Anyway
这就是我们讲QUEBEC的注册
那么其第三个系统呢
就是那个我们的消息分发系统
这个情况大家觉得应该很简单对吧
那我反正就是来了什么消息
我就问你们所有人都去
比如说我每一帧产生100个消息
然后呢
我每个机油就依次的根据我注册的quebec function
然后呢把所有的消息去扫一遍
然后呢少到了相应的函数
我就去分发
对不对
大家想想这样可不可以
事实上这样的你写也可以的
但是呢他的问题是它的效率非常非常的低
这里面有很多的问题了
比如说假设我每一帧产生N个消息
然后呢每个机油假设我产生NM个
这个这个这个就是这个这个就是它的那个
call back函数
然然后呢我有K歌这个GO
那你这个计算辅导的多少呢
就M乘N乘K
大家想想这个是不是很麻烦对吧
还有一个就是你的内存
是不是当这些消息过来的时候
这个这个这个消息比如一开始放一个去存
那以后使用包括这个消息释放掉
那这个每一次都从头这样扫的话
是不是会就会变得非常的慢
所以实际上的话呢就是说在我们的消息分
事实上是有一个分发机制的
最简单的分发机制就是我消息来了
马上就去扩扩别人
但这样会出一个什么问题呢
就会出现你前面一个函数执行中间会打断出来
来一段
它就会形成一小段
中间的这个这个这个就相当于你得等别人
就是大家如果学过那个KROUTINE的话
就知道那个时候哎我的主线程要停下来
我要等另外一件事做完
我再回来
我的还是在继续继续执行对吧
但是如果你是单线程的话
那也真的就等在那儿了
等他回来
那这个地方的话呢
它就会产生一个很有意思的问题
就是说假设我们这个世界在发生一个爆炸
比如说一个手雷炸了
他把旁边的另外一些手雷引爆了
那个手雷再去引爆
那你就会一个手雷产生那个引爆的event
就会触发另外一个另外几个手雷的
这个爆炸的这个疑问
然后就一层层一层层掉下去
最后你去看那个codex的时候
你就会发现它深不见底
我不知道大家有没有有没有这个debug
一些比较大型系统啊
就是比如说我们一个大型系统部署出去之后
然后呢他如果宕机了
你去看他的cost
有些时候如果系统架构都不好
你会发现你cos AI非常非常深
你就一路掉下去
而且呢同样名字的函数
它只是因为对象不同
在疯狂的在被重新扩
那个时候debug起来其实是非常的痛苦
所以呢就是如果你想立即执行这些
call back函数的话
它其实就有这样的一个问题
然后另外一个呢他还有一个很有意思的问题
就是刚才我讲的就是说你的每一个操作
如果他瞬时能完成对吧
这个动作我觉得还可以
问题不大
比如说我减一下血量
无非就是你的heal什么加减一个数值的事情
这个执行起来也非常的快
对不对
但是这个时候说哎因为我手雷要炸了
所以我现在要加一个爆炸的烟雾的效果
我要AI effect
那么在前面我们讲过离子系统
对不对
那么大家知道离子系统这个玩意儿
可是很费的对吧
我要创建的几百个particle
要算它的运动
而且要把它渲染出来
这个东西它实际上是并不能够瞬间做完了
但是呢其他所有的游戏逻辑
都在等着这个离子系统做完
那就会导致什么问题呢
就是在有些时候
你的游戏的帧率会突然一下子很不稳定
所以这样的架构呢
其实啊在游戏引擎很早的时代
大家就觉得不能这么干了
所以直接派发
其实它在这个地方产生的问题是蛮深
蛮蛮严重的
那么这个时候呢还有一个问题是什么
就是说我产生大量的事情
它在时间轴上不停的产生不同的event
这样就会导致就是说我我的调用是一层套一层
一层套一层
我没有办法把这个运算把它整个并行化对吧
大家还记得我们在前面讲过
就是其实后面会跟大家讲一些最简单的
比如说面向数据编程的架构
实际上在现代计算机
我动辄就是八个核甚至16个核
那如果我依次就是像串珠串一样吊在一起的话
那这个调用的话
它是很难形并行化的
所以这都是就是immediate调用
产生了一个很大的问题
那么所以呢
其实在现代的这个游戏引擎架构中的话呢
我们要做这样的一个叫这个这个event系统的话
一定要构建一个叫event q
就是我们会把所有的event全部
这一帧的event全部catch到一起
变成一个Q
然后呢我下一帧开始的时候
我各个机构依次来处理它
但这里面我要一个分发的过程
那么这个event q呢其实啊蛮有意思的
他首先呢大家会想象在内存中
或者说在我的引擎中
我们要有一个小小的
这个就是叫序列化和反序列化的系统
因为刚才讲的就是每个疑问它的类型不同
它的数据都不一样
对不对
但最后我的内存内存中存储的时候呢
我们是希望给他分一个叫block of memory
就是一一大块内存对吧
每一个疑问的邦邦邦邦邦
一个连一个的连起来连起来
所以这个时候我去把几百个event拍成一块内存块
然后呢拿到这个内存块之后
我要把它反向的拆成几百个event
其实这里面是有一个小小的
序列化和反序列化的过程的
那这个过程怎么实现的呢
以前大家会觉得很难对吧
那我要用无数的C加类型去派生和继承
但大家学过了我们讲的那个反射对吧
我们就知道每一个数据结构它的内存是多少
所以我只要拿到event它的描述结构的话
实际上我们就知道它内存有多大
所以这个时候你看反射就起作用了
那好我知道每个event的反射描述的话
其实你给我一段二进制的空间
一个一一段空间
我也可以反向的填回去
我一个C加的结构
所以其实event这里面对反射要的那个
就是用的地方是非常非常多的
那么我有了这么多event之后
接下来我怎么去管理内存
这里面大家一定要注意
就是我们一般用的是一个rain buffer
这个rain buffer的概念
大家这个在学数据结构的时候没有学过
其实非常的简单好用诶
你会发现我们在读书的时候
学的所有的数据结构
其实当我们去做大型工程的时候
它一定是有用的
所以像event这个事情就完美的适合这个ring buffer
就是说我们会假设说我每一帧最多
比如说我同时要存1000个一半的
或者是5000个一半的
那我就分配个rain buffer
这样的话呢我就不用每次再去申请新的内存
而我直接一直在重用这个rain的内容
这样我每次一个一般的处理完之后呢
其实我就可以把它head往前移一步对吧
如果我后面再去要加薪的疑问
我把它tell往后移
当然hit tell重合在一起
说明我的buffer已经overflow了
已经炸掉了
但这种情况的话
在游戏中很多时候都是你写出bug的一个标志
比如说你有一个机
错误的在不停的发出这个疑问的
这是有的
但是呢这个时候我们就会把这些U穷截断
这样的好处是什么呢
就是你的游戏逻辑可能会错误
甚至错只错误那么几帧
但是你整个引擎不会崩崩塌掉
所以的话呢
就是一般我们会推荐用ring buffer的方法
去管理这个event的这个这个这个池子好
那么其实呢就刚才讲的
就是说真正在这个现代游戏里面啊
你问的数量是蛮高的
那么如果我们不假思索的
把所有的event都放到了一起
那这个处理就是它便利的过程就很麻烦很费
我们讲过就是说A计算机是图灵机结构对吧
我们要把一秒钟就一帧里面
我要把几百个甚至上千元1万的过过滤完的话
而且给他根据在表里面去查收哦
因为你是这种疑问的
所以我要叫你那个call back
这个来回的调用其实是比较慢的
那怎么办呢
其实在游戏引擎架构中的话
我们一般会把event跟着几大类分掉
比如说网络event其实非常的多对吧
但是它的处理和其他的event没有什么关系
那我们就把所有的network event全放到一起
有单独的一个rain buffer来管理
单独的一个DISPU处理诶
所有战斗相关的
一般我们也把它放在一起
然后呢动画系统它有的时候也是个独立系统
我们也要放到一起
那这样的话实际上我们相当于把一个大的数据
把它分而治之了
这个呢在实践中
其实无论是对于提高我们的引擎的效率
还是提高我的引擎的这个DEBUGABILITY
就是说当你写这么复杂的引擎的时候
很多时候你会写错
那当你把消息呢这样分成几大类之后
再去追踪再去处理的话
实际上这个你一旦出错之后
你查起来真的很轻松
因为你很多时候就发现诶
此处应该有一个动画消息怎么没有产生
那你就不会买这个event q的去寻找
你只需要在那个就是说动画那个科研寻找
所以这个实际上是一个非常好的一个架构
所以同学们
我们在加我们的引擎的event系统的时候
会强烈的推荐大家
就是把这个消息分成几大类对吧
虽然理理想上原则上是这样
你是不需要分类
但是呢它会导致效率下降很多
那么其实呢event q呢它是还是有蛮多的问题的
就是刚才讲了哎
虽然我一上来就讲了
这个直接处理模式有很多的坏处对吧
大家也想是啊
这个简直就是一拍脑袋嘛
来了一件事
我就马上处理对吧
然后这样的话我一件事产生另外一件事
我就形成一个链式反应
最后这个东西很麻烦
所以还不如全部收集好
下一帧
我一起来处理
这个听上去是非常好的
但是呢它产生一个比较大的问题
第一个就是你这个消息执行的顺序
我是不能保证的
为什么呢
举个例子啊
比如说啊我动画系统对吧
我的AI系统
我的战斗系统
其实在很多游戏引擎里面
它的执行顺序都是固定死的
但是有的时候我的有些业务逻辑
我是希望先处理动画再去处理物理
再去处理战斗
有的有的人呢我是希望先处理战斗
再去处理动画对吧
有的时候我是战斗行为决定了我的动画行为
但是的话呢你的event系统去处理的时候
他统一到下一帧了
下一帧之后同一类的消息全集中到一起
其实你并不能保证它的这样的一个执行的效率
而执行的顺序
这时候当我们在写这样的逻辑的时候
我们就要保证这个逻辑具有一定的健壮性
其实这也是很多游戏特别容易产生bug的地方
其实这个问题说句实话
在现在游戏引擎里面
一直都是一个非常难以解决的问题
甚至有时候我们为了解决这个问题
我们会hard扣的一些东西
所以其实在引擎里面有的时候有些疑问
我们甚至保留立即处理的能力
但这里面都是要很精心的设计过的
比如说我会有一个疑问
我故意塞在那边
还有就是有些函数我故意放在里面
我会去去安全性的改一些数据
所以其实真正的一般在TK的时候比较复杂的
就是我记得有三种
一种是啊
正常的就是你下一帧一上来就处理完对吧
还有一种呢是你在我这一帧TIK完之后
在我的post tik的地方
我把它处理完
所有的有的有的一般是在叫post tik处理
有的在critic处理
有的呢就是真的是immediate的处理了
所以实际上一个现代游戏引擎的话呢
它三种方法都要支持的
但这三种方法怎么去用
其实是要求这个程序员
他对这个系统的调用方式非常的理解
这个地方就特别特别容易产生bug
其实到目前为止
我觉得还有一个很难的问题
我自己也没想明白
就是说啊我作为一个程序员
我是能理解诶
什么时候该用那个PRE
什么时候用post
什么时候用media immediate
但是的话我怎么把这件事情告诉我们的设计师
让我们设计师非常用错
设计师很多时候是很蛋疼的
觉得这个是很麻烦
那么另外一个的话呢
就是这个啊event这种处理机制呢
大部分情况下
所有的行为都会是在下一帧再处理
所以呢当我一个复杂的
这个就是说递进关系的逻辑
就是因为EVA触发了even的B
even的B出问C他整个过程都是一次要慢一帧
所以在有一些你希望时时能发生的事情的时候
诶这个疑问那就比较麻烦了
我举个例子吧
比如说我们做打击感对吧
你这一刀在这一帧检测到
我这刀砍到了那个我们的敌人
唉那个时候你希望比如说正品
你希望标选一个效果
几乎在同一帧渲染到你屏幕上
这样你的打击感才能到最好
对不对
但是呢如果按照event的方法的话呢
很多时候比如说你这一针砍上去之后
诶
你下一帧可能先是health系统
去这个线下一帧那个particle能够出来了
你看到飙血这个时候在这个这个时候
health系统也能检测到说哦这是这是一次暴击
好
那我再发出疑问的说
我要屏幕抖一下好
再下一帧屏幕抖一下
你想这个一刀砍上去
我看到飙血是一针之后了
然后呢在我看到那个屏幕抖动的时候
已经是两针之后了
那么两帧是多少呢
两针几乎是100ms之后了
那其实你的打击感是不是感觉就不对了
这其实也是就是event的系统
当我们在用的时候
要非常小心地规避这个问题
所以很多时候你这个地方需要hard code直接绕过去
这个就是他的latency对吧
所以这是invent q在用的时候
在真实的做做游戏引擎中
大家一定要小心的东西
但是呢不妨碍invent q是一个非常重要的一个
Game play
就是玩法系统的基础系统好
那么其实这个地方相当于
我们把第二节课提的这个概念
就是这个消息分发处理的逻辑
这次算彻底跟大家讲清楚了
就是你要做一个游戏文化系统
你首先需要有这样的一个消息处理机制
作为你的foundation
那么大家现在也能大概能明白
就是说消息的处理其实有三种方法
一种是就是叫马上处理
另外一种呢就是这个下一帧处理
下一帧处理呢又分为两种叫PRE和post对吧
更细节的东西呢同学们自己去掌握了好
那么有了这样一个东西之后
接下来就说诶
那我们是不是可以开始写游戏的逻辑了
游戏的玩法了对吧
我就可以按照我的想法设计各种各样
我想要的游戏了呢啊原则上是可以的
那最简单的写法怎么样呢
我就直接用C加写死了
对不对
那么在早期的游戏开发中
还真的就是这么干的对吧
因为那个时候说实话游戏还是蛮简单的
我们可以做的
就像你做一个FPS游戏
实际上你用C加加写真的能写出来
而且它的效率肯定是最高的
那么我自己在当时读高中的时候嘛
那时候我刚刚在学习编程
我印象特别深
就是我用汇编写了个俄罗斯方块哇
这个我当时还记得那些代码大概是几千行代码
那个汇编写下来
然后我就觉得哇
这个汇编语言真的是世界上最工整的语言
因为汇编语言每一行的指令它的长度都差不多
不像你写高级语言
就是像狗啃的一样
一会长
一会短
汇编语言看起来非常非常工整
然后一段一段一段一段哇
这个感觉特别好
所以特别有成就感
但是呢大家知道这样的东西它是难以为继的
因为当我们的游戏变得越来越复杂的时候
那这样的高级语言的话
或者是这样的编译语言
它其实是有非常多的问题了
那么最大的问题是什么呢
就是说你每改一点点的游戏的这个game play
你的整个游戏引擎就得重新编一次对吧
这个是很蛋疼的
很头疼的一件事
那么第二个很头疼的问题是什么呢
就是说其实啊当我们的游戏真的发布出去之后
大家知道最容易出的问题是什么
有各种各样的bug对吧好
你经常玩买了一个游戏有bug
特别是你玩网游有个bug对吧
我这个跳起来暴击别人始终达不到
这个肯定是游戏系统写了bug
或者说一个装备掉落总是错的
这种情况怎么办
诶如果作为游戏开发者
你说他急不急
他很急的
但是他再给你推一个新的版本吗
把这bug修好嘛
那这个事情你肯定不愿意
对不对
那怎么办
其实有个很重要的东西叫做hot update
叫热更新
其实大家如果现在在玩网游啊
就几乎所有的网游
他们都是一个刚需的东西
叫做热更新
就是你为什么会经常玩一游戏
玩着玩着玩的过程中间
你突然发现诶官方推了一个东西
你的bug就好了
其实这个东西就是用热更新的机制
而所有的编译语言
比如像C加加
它就非常难以热更新
但是你真的硬生生的要hack其实也是可以的
但那个就会变得非常的麻烦对吧
所以其实编译型语言的话呢
在热更新方面的这个挑战是蛮多的
而且每一点改动都要重新编译
甚至把整个游戏宁可一遍
就像我刚才讲的时候
宁可不好
你肯定要link半小时过去
那对开发的效率影响非常非常的大
所以这个时候呢
这个天降这个
这个这里面还有一个第三个挑战是什么呢
就是说那个在游戏开发中啊
我们总觉得玩法是我们程序员去想的对吧
我们做过玩法系统
但实际上它的最大的用户不是程序员
是设计师
而设计师呢
他本身并没有受过非常良好的这样的一个
就是编程训练
你让他去写C加代码对吧
人家设计师学的不是这个东西
人家学的是如何设计一个好玩的游戏
那么好
那设计师的话
他需要有能力自己去定义各种各样的玩法
各样的东西
那其实你如果让他直接改那个C加代码
这件事情也是很痛苦的
包括有些艺术家
他也需要去定制一些游戏的功能
一些玩法
那怎么办
你怎么去驱动这个事情
所以呢诶这个时候就天降猛男了
就是这个脚本语言
脚本语言呢诶这个时候真的是就是特别特别好
他首先的话呢就是非常简单易学易上手
第二个的话呢它热更新很方便
很多消费语言都是这种解释知识性语言
所以说你把代码一更新
诶
他的整个这个逻辑全部就变了
反正他代码是走到一步看一步嘛
大家以前有没有学过那个有个语言叫basic语言
对吧
这是最简单的语言
现在我不知道现在应该在vb了
那么basic语言就是我以前印象特别深
我以前学pasta学C的时候
他告诉我说这是编译语言
basic语言就是个解释语言
所以解释言的好处是什么
就是内行函数执行之前你把函数换掉了
它可以继续按照新的逻辑去运转
所以非常的方便
另外一个呢就是说它非常适合是什么呢
就是说脚本语言它一般运行在一个虚拟机上面
所以其实它是在一个沙箱里面运行
所以脚本语言很多时候他可以自己crush
但是呢他不会把你的引擎的本体crush掉
就很多时候你会发现
比如说我写了一个脚本的逻辑
但这个逻辑如果crash掉之后的话呢
哎我大不了再重新rise这个东西有逻辑就好了
我给大家举个例子啊
比如说这个东西在什么地方特别有用呢
就是在写非常复杂的网络游戏的服务器端
大家可能不能想象
就是我们一个大型的M游戏的话
它一旦跑起来
背后可能是几百个这个进程
同时在启动
做各种各样的工作
有的人专门负责聊天
有的有的人专门负责发邮件
这几百个进程或者县城在各个机器上
其实随时都有可能会挂掉
但是为什么你们去玩那些大型网络游戏
好像很少宕机呢
实际上我们背后都会做这样一个系统
就是我们一旦发现某个服务挂掉了之后
我们会把那个服务重新启动
重新通过脚本重新把它接入进去
所以说这个其实也是脚本语言很核心的一个
一个好处
就是它能够就是说A不会把本体crush掉
所以这个呢其实是诶
刚才我们抛的问题的一个很好的解
那么脚本语言呢它是怎么工作的呢
其实也蛮简单的
就是说你写出脚本
它本质上就是一些文文本对吧
文本通过他的自己的编译器编译成一堆的bad code
那个这个bad code呢
其实一般来讲都是他们自己定义的
非常的简单
就比如说每个instruction
就是诶我到底做过什么操作
然后呢我的这个这个这个到底是哪些数字
相加相乘
然后内存应该怎么移动
非常非常简单
然后变成一段那个二进制的一个blog
然后呢它有一个就是虚拟机
虚拟机呢就去执执行他自己编出来bad code
然后呢就可以这样整个run起来了
所以你可以认为就是它整个是在
你这个怎么说呢
可以说是在游戏操作系统之上
又跑了一个虚拟机
这就是为什么它本身可以变得非常的鲁棒
当然了
它也是有代价的
代价就是它速度可能会比较慢
那么其实呢当脚本语言
它提供了这样所有的服务之后呢
它其实就可以把很多的业务逻辑移到脚本里面
比如大家现在去看很多的那个游戏啊
特别是网游
他的脚本语言用的特别特别多
比如说大名鼎鼎的这个魔兽争霸对吧
那么他就用一己之力
带带带来了整个中国游戏行业
大家都喜欢用UI这个脚本语言
对不对
所以我们的脚本语言你就会写很多很多逻辑
比如说啊开宝箱对吧
大家最恨的开宝箱的东西
比如说我打装备
打个东西刷装备对吧
这个东西我一个玩法
比如说我交一个任务会触发什么什么事情
这些东西很多时候都是用脚本去写的
那么而且脚本还有个好处
就是策划也可以写
那这里面的话呢就是作为引擎测
我们去想
就是在脚本语言和我们的引擎之间
一个最难最难的一个问题是什么呢
是对象的管理
就是游戏里面的一个机诶
我们一直在讲游戏引擎里面都是有机油
对不对
但这节课你们就会讲到一个有意思的问题
就是机油到底归谁管
比如说在我的脚本语言
你比如UI里面
我每一个游戏里面的NPC诶
我都有一个他的肌肉对象
对不对
然后呢我在引擎里面的每个NPC呢
它也有一个自己的机会对象好
那这个NPC是谁负责管理他的整个生命周期
谁负责去销毁它
这件事情其实并没有那么简单
原因很简单
就比如说你走出了一个主城对吧
你走进一个主人
你面前蹦蹦蹦出了这个几十个NPC好吧
你看他交任务对话完了之后
你走出去之后
这NPC是不是要被销毁掉了
否则你的内存一直不得占用了吗
哎问题就来了
到底是咱们C加代码写的游戏引擎呢
还是我们交给这个就是脚本
你的系统去管它
其实这件事情
在游戏引擎设计的时候是非常关键的
那么这里面有两种不同的流派了
比如说有一类人认为我的这个引擎代码
C加写的效率是最高的
而且呢我做了大量的这个安全性测测试
那我把这些机油呢
全部把它放到这个就是引擎内核去管理对吧
我100个NPC我玩好了
NPC逻辑坏了
你给我发个指令
我把它删掉
这种做法呢其实是啊
应该来讲是没有什么太大问题的
但这些要求我的脚本里面
每一次去访问这些机油的时候
我得问问这个对象有没有销毁掉
而且呢就是引擎写这个对象的管理的时候
他要写得相对比较严谨一点
那么因为大家知道
就是很多引擎是用C加加写的嘛
那C加引擎它的内存管理一旦做不好之后
就很容易造成内存泄露对吧
那么这个它它但是产生的问题是什么呢
就是说
其实随着我们在脚本里的业务逻辑越来越复杂
很多机构的创建消亡
实际上是由游戏玩法决定的
打个比方
比如说你扔出了一个什么道具
啪啪啪
他突然变成了三个小怪物出来对吧
三个小怪物呢
它还能向你去砸那个什么这个石头
打个比方
那这个三个小怪物它是不是G对不对
那这个机构的创建我还需要到引擎再绕一圈吗
好吧
而且这个创建的逻辑
其实在小本里写的最简单的对吧好
这小怪物开始看见你了
就不停的打
你就变出石头来砸你变出来的石头
它又是机油对吧
这个机油又是脚本系统自身产生的那好
那难道这些小石头也要在我的引擎里的
整个转一圈吗
那这个过程它就会变得非常非常的麻烦
所以你会发现一个很有意思的事情
就是说在一些玩法非常丰富和复杂的
游戏里面的诶
大家会说我把机油它的创建和管理
交给脚本系统
就脚本系统来负责创建这些对象
这些对象并且去交互
然后呢
引擎呢只是引用到这些脚本系统创新的机构
但是它本身不负责他生命收集的管理
那脚本系统怎么去销毁这些东西呢
哎这里面就讲了一个大名鼎鼎的系统
就前面已经提到了叫GC
GGC的英文全称叫garbage collection
就是垃圾回收器对吧
它会就是几乎所有的脚本系统都有这个GC系统
就是说如果我发现我的这些对象
没有人再需要用它了
好
我就专门找个时间把这个对象给清掉
那么大家如果写过c#语言的对吧
写过java语言的
写过其他所有脚本语言
都知道这个GGC系统
cc系统是一个让大家又爱又恨的一个系统
爱它就是真的省事
不会像C加加对吧
动不动会遇到什么野指针啊
动不动会遇到什么这个内存泄漏这种问题对吧
真的是无脑的创建对象
无脑的用它
然后呢用完就扔
不用管
过一段时间期
最后把你处理掉
但是GC会产生的问题是什么呢
就是他这个算法特别的慢对吧
他每一次要整个扫描这个这个context
里面的引用关系
所以大家如果去分析一下
比如说举个例子
像UI你去看
如果你的脚本写的非常的复杂的话
那个GC系统运转的效率会非常低的
甚至在一些复杂的游戏产品里面
GC本身要吃掉整个游戏时间的
可能是1/10左右
我去收集这所有的那个这个资产
其实我跟所有的错
那个就是说这种就是重度脚本型的游戏的
这种特别复杂的MO的这种游戏的团队
交流的时候
大家很核心的在一起聊的就是如何优化GC
让这个GC不要占用我太多的时间
所以这两种方法呢都有各有利弊
但是完全取决于你的游戏类型
那么我觉得就是取决于你的引擎
如果我们的引擎是做的本身啊
对象没有那么多
没有那么复杂
但更多的是一种很重度的这种啊
角色细节的表现
比如说我相信你就这么几十个对象
但是呢它有很多很丰富的动作
AI的这种细节
那这个东西的话呢
我会倾向于把它的生命周期用引擎去管理对吧
那这样的话呢
就是说他其实在欧美单机游戏动画
很多时候对象他都是在这个引擎里面管理的
但是对于比较复杂
就是业务特别特别复杂
而且经常会因为玩法会产生大量的新的GO的
这样的一个游戏
比如说像最典型的就是MRPG对吧
那这里面的对象都特别多
而且非常多的系统
各种各样的玩法
那一般来讲的话呢
哎我们会把生命周期放在脚本里面去管理
这样的话呢在玩法系统里面
我们可以很容易地创建和销毁
各种各样的物体对象
所以其实我很难说哪个方法好
其实各有利弊
那我也非常希望就是在下一代的引擎设计中
这个问题呢彻底的解决
但目前真的是如果我们引入脚本的时候
这个对象到底归谁管
其实是一个两边会打拉扯的一个东西
那么其实还有更有意思的问题
就是说大家想象一下
如果我们今天去用脚本系统
在我们的引擎中
大家最自然的想法是什么
哎我的引擎写的很厉害
很牛逼对吧
我的引擎每每一帧都是tick
当我到有些业务逻辑的时候
本来比如说我想写的这个AI系统
我想写的一个玩法
比如说我走过去把门一开
这个门上会有些灯去闪一闪这些东西诶
我可以把它变成一个脚本
所以是引擎去调用脚本
到了某个特定特定的
比如说component的时候
我把那一段它相应的处理写成脚本对吧
这个逻辑是成立不成立成立的
比如像unity引擎里面就是这个啊
它的原生态
就是说哎你每个component可以扩展成一个脚本
然后用c#去写写的就可以了
但其实啊还有一类这个引擎非常有意思的架构
就是它是用脚本包引擎
这个架构呢现在大家谈的不多啊
但是我一直觉得
这也是值得大家去思考的一个东西
就是说实际上你可以把引擎变成一个SDK库
就是引擎提供了各种各样基础的服务
然后呢唉是由脚本来控制整个tick的flow
到了那个时候调侃说tick animation好
引擎傻乎乎的把所有的机构animation tik1遍
脚本说嗯你们这些animation可以
这些机构可以休息了
那就应该干掉
然后呢他给一个名名单过去
引擎把这些机构给干掉
所以其实呢还有一类架构
就是说我有脚本反过来的去爆音擎
现在具体的游戏我已经不记得了
但是我记得在早期的游戏游戏产品
而且是很著名的大作里面
他用的架构还真的就是交不爆音情
但是现在的话呢这种结构我记得已经有点少了
就是说但这两种思路的话呢
我觉得大家都可以考虑
其实如果你走方法二的话
实际上你就把引擎变成了一个什么呢
变成了一个啊
我可以认为是个SDK集吧
就是用用脚本反过来去扩他的service
各种各样的服务
所以这两种架构的话
大家在做自己的引擎架构的时候可以考虑
如果你想走方案二的话
其实你引擎暴露出什么接口
是要认真的设计过的
那么其实呢今天要讲的就是说
脚本有个很重要的特性
就是它能够热更新
那这里面我就不展开复杂了
就讲个非常简单的点
就是热更新怎么去实现呢
其实讲透了是非常的简单
就是脚本语言的热更新
很多时候他就是把那个函数时间给修改掉了
就是说他以前老的函数有个函数指针对吧
我我扩这个函数的时候
那我就到这个指针执行这个函数
诶
你来了一个新的函数的时候
我把它指成重新指向我的新的视线
那我的热更新就已经实现了
但注意一点
就是说在引擎在那个脚本里面有很多的local
variable啊
或者是函数里面的这些vb
有些人你viable
它是这个全局变量
那这些变量的话
当我们在写脚本的时候
热更新的时候
这些变量注意一定要重置
或者一定要把数据这个进行必要的处理
所以否则的话呢你热更新不好
就会导致整个游戏的崩塌
那大家会觉得哎我去写热更新的时候
我肯定会小心了
对不对
写错了
我大不了重新启动一下
大家在所有在做游戏引擎的同学都会这么讲
一开始入行的时候
但是我要跟大家讲
就是当这个引擎
真正作为一个商业级的游戏引擎的时候
你就没有那么快活了
因为音响啊就是你的一个游戏
现在有上百万人同时在玩对吧
然后的话呢很多人在做很重要的操作
比如有人正在做充值操作
有的人正在点开他的那个时装箱
对不对
有人正在打一个很重要的boss
你老人家这个地方假设热更新把人家搞坏了
那这可能就有几千甚至上万人同时找你
讨要我的装备对吧
讨要我那个boss
那个boss我已经快打完了
突然你把我的引擎崩掉了
所以其实在游戏引擎架构的时候
特别考虑的就是工程上的一种鲁棒性
这个也是当我们就是从
其实今天我们讲的这个脚本系统
实际上就已经讲了
游戏引擎一个很有意思的概念
就是很多人在问我说
哎你们的游戏引擎是用什么语言去写的呀
然后我每次就很尴尬
我说这个很难讲啊
因为我们会用到十几种完全不同的语言
就是在每一个不同的场景下
肯定有个语言更适合他
比如说服务器你会用go语言对吧
那么你在这个就是说呃脚本那个地方
你可能会有UI
你可能用CSHUI
你还会有一些地方你管理服务器
你可以用Python
对不对
然后你有的地方用CC加加对不对
然后包括也会用一些java
包括你前端还要用一些语言
所以其实一个真正的现代游戏引擎啊
它是一个复合体
各种音调在一起混合去编程
所以当我们去实现我们的引擎和脚本系统
对接的时候
其实就是大家第一次能感受哎
这个脚就混合编程
做这种大型系统这种概念
所以反过来讲的话
就是在我们今天开课的第一开始
同学跟我们说
AIKA要不要实现脚本系统
我我刚才也在讲的
就是说这件事情的话呢
其实支持一个简单的
比如UI脚本
其实难度并不大的
但是呢我会觉得
就是等我们这个PUI本身做的再稳定一点之后
同学们有兴趣的话
我们一起可以来设计一下
就是哎对PUI这么小小的引擎
它的脚本系统该怎么接入
该怎么去开放哪些接口
包括那些接口函数怎么去注册
这些地方有很多很有意思的小细节
那我们大家一起探讨
所以说你想把一个脚本系统和引擎
结合的好的话呢
哎真的是要花那么一点点的时间去好好想想它
它的架构
那么其实呢脚本语言有很多好处了对吧
但脚本语言最大的坏处其实也非常明显的
就是第一个也是最这个大家最诟病的是什么
就是它的这个效率太低对吧
大家知道就是比如说啊C车哪个哪个圆最快
C加肯定是最快的
对不对
那你java肯定会慢一点的
c#其实速度还可以
但是你如果用了UI的这种语言的话
它的速度就会比那个原声语言慢很多
但是呢就是这个有一种很有意思的东西
叫什么呢
叫jet
就just in time
就是说像ui jet是大名鼎鼎了
就是说诶我虽然是解释执行的
但是呢我可以一边解释
我一边编译
等下一次的时候
我就直接run那个机器码
其实jet这个这种方式啊
其实本身是非常好的一种方式
就是呃我记得以前我们以前讨论过一个问题
就是到底是编译语言快还是js in time的语言快
大家会说那肯定是编译好的语言快
对不对
CAI写好了肯定是最快的对吧
但事实上呢
就是JAI语言有一个很厉害的一个属性
就是说他一边运行一边编译的时候
他可以知道你代码执行的路径
比如说假设我代码中有大量的if else if else分支
你会发现有些分支
在99%点几的情况下
他都不会出道
就把可能你整个这个脚本乱完之后
那个分支都会出不到
唉
借他他就知道
他就会直接把那些分支全部优化掉
所以理论上讲的话呢
就是在很多情况下
jet如果做得好
他理论上是可以超过你的编译语言的
但是我没有那么贪心的要求啊
就是我觉得啊
你只要比那个解释执行快就可以了
但实际上这一点gt我觉得做的还是挺不错的
就是现在的比如像ui jet这个语言的话
它实际上比原生态的UI大概能快一个数量级
是没有什么太大问题的
所以的话呢其实这个脚本语言的话呢
这个问题其实解决的还是蛮好的
就是像UI1些简单语言
那接下来还有个很有趣的问题是什么呢
就是说哎我们在写C语言或c#
这种语言的话呢
它面向对象的结构做的非常的好
但是的话呢就是像很多的脚本语言
他们是这个叫wk type的
就叫弱类型语言
比如像UI里面
你创建一个对象
它是没有类型的
你根本不知道什么东西对吧
它的好处就是什么东西都往里面塞对吧
你无论是一个结构还是一个函数
还是什么东西都往里面塞
意思
反正都都可以调用
但是它的坏处就是说
哎你去反射它里面真正到底什么数据的时候
还是挺麻烦的
你得去抠到UI里面的结构
你是能抠出来的
但这个可能效率会比较低
所以这也是我们在用脚本语言的时候
有的时候会遇到一些比较头疼的一些问题
那么其实呢所以说不同的引擎啊
它会根据自己的选择选择引擎
比如说刚才提到的
就是说比如说这个我们一般挑语言的时候
我们看它自身的这个build的feature是不是足够好
比如有的语言它的内裤非常的丰富
很多操作一行指令就就处理完了
对不对
那么有些的话呢就是它的效率非常的高
很轻量
内存占用很低
那么还有一些脚本语言的话呢
就是说哎它的面向对象封装的特别好
这样你不用自己再去分
这些比较复杂的数据结构
所以其实我们再去这个寻找这个游戏引擎的
脚本语言的时候
这些因素都要去考虑
对面举几个例子吧
比如说像这个魔兽世界对吧
他用一己之力把这个UI这个语言
介绍给了整个中国游戏行业
那么UI语言它的最大特点是什么呢
就是轻量
它的虚拟机真的非常非常的轻
非常的节约你的内存
然后呢效率也很高
因为它和C加加的接口效率也做的非常高
但是它的特缺点是什么呢
就非常的啊
基本上的内裤都没有
就是各种各样的这个扩展都没有
很多东西都需要你自己去写
那么这里面的话呢
另外一个语言就反其道而行的就是Python
对大名鼎鼎的Python那个我印象特别深
就是我以前学Python的时候
那本书上面画了一条巨大的舌音
Python的意思就是大蛇嘛
那么Python语言大家如果现在去学一些
我忘了
前段时间大家特别火
都要学Python了
人人都要学Python
对不对
学数据处理
学大数据你都要用Python
对不对
因为Python的好处就是什么
他的库特别的强大和丰富
但是它的缺点是什么呢
就是说哦他还有object
它是面向对象的
我记得当时我们在最早在接UI
这个这个脚本的时候
我们还犯了一个错误
就是我们觉得UI哎呀这个弱类型对吧
实在是太难管理了
作为程序员的小故事
我们把UI整个改造成了面向对象
最后出了什么问题呢
就会导致UI的GC就是那个垃圾回收特别的慢
后来我们上了ui jet之后
发现哎呀这个BGT基本上不能加速
因为你没有按照他最原生态的那个方法去写
那这一点反而Python是做的很好
Python面向对象天然的对吧
而且呢有非常强大的扩展库去支撑它
但是Python的问题是什么呢
就是非常的重对他虚拟机一旦跑起来之后
你可能几百兆内存就没有了
所以只Python的问题
那么现在在引擎里面呢
大家也开始慢慢的
因为有mono这样的库
包括当net现在也官方的支持这样的库
就是说我们可以把c#
这种原生态的编译语言变成一个脚本语言
那么C72P有很大的好处
就是学起来成本非常的低
基本上你学过C加加和C语言之后
其实你会非常容易理解C12
第二个的话呢就是说cc sharp的话
它本身的社区各种库的支撑也是非常强大的
所以其实现在已经有越来越多的这个团队
也在考虑用c#作为它的扩展语言
那么最大名鼎鼎的就是unity对吧
unity就是完全依托于CJB的可扩展性
这里面其实我认为是选这个选择
还是很smart的一件事情
那么其实各种语言的话
你会发现当我们去比较它的时候
诶比较它的性能对吧
那这里面毫无疑问
UI一般是比较最慢的
Python也好不到哪去
Python有时候也慢
但是c#的话呢
他去执行的时候效率会高很多
但是呢在以内存为基的话
诶这个UI是最省内存的
那么Python还是一样很费内存
那是CCCHP呢
相对来讲中间找到了一个平衡
所以说呢我们在设计游戏引擎的时候
我们确实要非常仔细的寻找
我们的脚本语言应该是什么
所以到时候同学们可以投票啊
就是我们如果PULLA后面开始
决定做他的脚本语言的时候
大家会选说我们到底是用UI还是用Python
还是CH对吧
说不定我们可以根据大家的投票
选择我们PICOLA的脚本语言
那讲完了脚本语言
大家基本上知道了脚本之后呢
就知道怎么去写各种各样的游戏玩法了
因为你已前面有一个max系统
然后脚本就相当于是你可以对各种各样的玩法
对吧
写坏了也没关系
大不了一个热更新
重新再更新上去
所以这是脚本语言很棒的一个东西
那接下来就再讲一个大家更加喜闻乐见的
就是visual scripting
就是说哎可视化的脚本语言对吧
可视化脚本
那什么叫可视化脚本呢
那其实就是这个大名鼎鼎的blueprint蓝图系统
对吧啊
还有什么呢
就是现在UI现在也要退的
就very scripting这个系统对吧
那这些东西其实不只是两个引擎了
其实基本上现在的游戏引擎
都要提供这种可视化的这个脚本功能
那为什么我们需要可视化的脚本功能呢
其实很多时候是我们忽视了一件事情
比如像我我自己是程序员出身
我很多时候不太理解
说哎呀明明写一个加减乘除
写个if else判断对吧
我用语言写起来不是很快嘛
很方便嘛
实在不行
我写脚本嘛对吧
程序员其实蛮喜欢写脚本的
但是为什么我们要做一个这么复杂的一个
就是可视化的这个编程系统的
其实后来我我们才意识到说
因为对于很多非程序背景的游戏开发者
比特别像设计师和艺术家
那么你让他去编程这件事情其实成本非常的高
而且你可以想象一个设计师
他想写一行
写几行代码
真的能编译
通过这个事儿就已经哭爹喊娘了
很多时候他根本不知道变量的声明啊
不知道变量的生命周期管理呀
实际上这件事情就变得非常的不可控
而且呢就是说我们写代码经常会写错对吧
逻辑写错了
因为你比如说对象内心用错了呀
函数这个调的不对呀
这些问题你在写这个五写这个代码的时候
其实你看不出来的
你只有执行的时候知道
但是的话呢可视化的这种脚本的话
实际上通过各种提示
各种关系锁定
把这些所有的error提前给你屏蔽掉
这样的话又会极大的方便
我们的艺术家和设计师
来创造他想要的游戏玩法
所以说这就是为什么在现代引擎中
可视化的脚本变得越来越这个受欢迎
也就是这个道理
那么可视化的脚本是怎么去做的呢
接下来我们讲一下这个它的设计设计结构
OK稍等
我先喝点水
好嗯然后呢其实怎么去理解可视化的脚本呢
其实啊你就把它想象成一种编程语言
大家如果学过任何一种最简单的编程语言
你知道编程语言有哪些要素呢
首先你要定义一个变量
对不对
然后呢你要去写函数
你要去写表达式对吧
表达式是什么呢
就加减乘除含一些函数
是不是函数啊
就是比如说一些一些语句
这些语句什么执行一些动作
比如print在屏幕上打印一个东西对吧
或者在屏幕上画画一条线
那么这些这个这些语句还有什么呢
还有这个控制流对吧
If else
对不对
我要控制他整个行为还有什么呢
诶我把一一大堆的操作
把它包装成一个包体
包装成一个函数
这样的话方便我以后更加多次的
方便的去调用它
然后呢
类似的功能和它的这个
就是说数据我打成一个包
变成一个类的定义
那么其实就是我们很多
几乎是所有的现代语言的一个定义吧
但这个是一个呃不是这个叫面向函数编程
就是我们传统的就是传统式的编程
我们就有这些要素
对不对
那这些要素呢
其实就是当我设计一个可视化编程系统的时候
你要对对抗
你要看这个要素
那这里面的话呢
我们接下来就举用unreal的blueprint为例
因为BOEPRINT我个人比较下来
我认为是做得最成熟的
也是最老牌的这样的一个可视化脚本语言
所以它里面很多概念基本上是完整的实现了
那么首先你看一个变量
那其实变量呢最核心的就是说诶
我每个变量它到底是什么类型的对吧
它是个布尔型
它是个int型
它是个还是个颜色对吧
还是一个向量
还有一个是什么呢
诶这个变量的作用域
这个听起来有点复杂了
对不对
这个变量是在我这个本地自己算算的
还是我的变量是来自于外面的
比如说A啊
这个角色的血量是跟这个角色相关的
对不对
那么整个世界的温度
那是整个世界的相关的
所以每个变量它实际上是有自己的作用域的
对吧
你一个角色的血量的变化
不会影响其他角色的血量
更不会影响世界的温度
所以每一个变量有自己的scope
所以其实呢在这个就是编程语言里面
就是在这个这个script语言里面
那个这个graph那个图里面的话呢
哎我们就通过拐角的方法去定义了
各种各样的变量
那这里面变量之间它会进行赋值吗
其实几乎所有的可视化的编程语言
它都会用不同形状或者颜色的拐角
来定义数据类型
这样就避免你把错误的数据接入到他的输出了
当然这里面还有一个特殊的处理
就是说比如说有些可以直接进行类型转换的
比如说你float可以直接转成int对吧
int可以转成float
那像AI你们的做法是什么呢
诶他会给你直接加一个类型转换器
但这个都是细节了
所以其实这个拐角的设计啊
实际上对艺术家来讲非常的方便
为什么呢
因为它只要看到绿色就绿色蓝色蓝色就好了
它就不用再去管其他的事情了
那么包括它的鼠标移上去的时候
如果你正在运行的时候
debug的时候
你能看到它的数值到底是多少
大家想想
这个时候大家的理解就是说
为什么可视化编程态度它有很大的一个优势了
因为我们以前在写C语言的时候
经常会把数据的类型复杂
当然了
编译器会告诉我们这个事错了
但现在你用这种就是可视化编程的话
它直接就不让你连了
这样就更简单对吧好
有了这个变量之后呢
其实我们就可以进行语句或者是表达式
那其实表达式呢其实相对比较简单一点
就是说比如说加减乘除
包括现在所有的visual script语言的话
他会都给你
会给你highlight
说你是做个加法
你还是做个大小比喻
那个比较你还是做个乘法
就是都有一个巨大的一个符号的明显显示
那这里面的话一个很重要的节点
就是这个语句就是做一个动作
其实在几乎所有的steam machine啊
或者说蓝图啊这种语法里面
你会看到一个类似三角形的这样一个符号
这个符号就表示说这个地方我要执行的语句
这个语句是个动作
我这个动作做完了之后
我再回去做下一个动作
像刚才我举个例子
就比如说我想我想在屏幕上打印出一行字
这是什么
这是一个动作
对不对
那我指向去那边
Excement print as a string
然后呢这里面你可以输出一个变量
你的你的这个string
就是你这个字符串到底是什么东西
哎你这个语这个语句执行完之后
可能在游戏上面的那个就是控制面板
会打印出一行字出来
当然我们可以做的更复杂一点
比如说我这个动作是让屏幕相机抖三抖对吧
一样的抖三抖完了之后
我再去走下一个flow
所以说statement就是说在我们的整个这个可创一年
你实际上真正的执行的flow是用这个语句走
但是呢还有很多的就是说进行这种表达式运算
那么在可视化引擎
另外一类呢就是我们的control flow
就各种各样的control flow
那其实呢也比较简单
比如说哎比较大小对吧
然后的话呢我们要求你们就比如说依次执行
那这里面其实他就用刚才那个语句
那边的那个三角形的符号
你会发现control flow里面很多时候
有的时候是数据的比较
有的时候是执行的比较
这两种东西呢都会区分开来
所以大家去理解这个
就是说可视化种编程语言的时候
实际上你把这些东西能够串起来的话
你基本上就能形成任何一种你想要的逻辑
那这里面我选的全是blue处理为例啊
但是如果你真的理解这个基础结构的话啊
实话实说
你做一个简单的类似于那个不print系统
其实难度并不像大家想的那么大对吧
特别像现在你有了WPF非常方便的帮你做UI
然后呢你又懂脚本语言的话
其实你用这些东西呢
形成一个基本上一个简易的可视化编程语言
其实比如说像有些游戏引擎啊
我见过比如说当我们做这个叙事结构
做了个叫store flow
那其实也可以用这种方法去形成它的整个flow
其实也是类似于一个脚本
那么在实战中的话呢
我们也会发现就是两个问题
第一个就是诶我有很多的运算
我把它我会经常会调用它
而且呢我希望他有更清晰的输出和输出
那我们在高级语言中引入了一个东西叫做函数
大家想象一下函数出来之前的话
我们写一段代码
是不是从头写到尾
几千行就一路写下来
对不对
然后呢我不能执行的时候
我就降不过去
那么后来大家引
我就在汇编里面引入了函数的概念
那好那函数的话呢
它就可以很方便地把一系列的这种这个操作
打包到一起
然后呢它就会抽象出哪些是我的输入
但是呢我还注意函数的执行入口只有一个对吧
然后呢A函数的执行出口可能有很多个
然后呢进入到我的函数的外面的东西
那这样我的函数就可以形成一个接电单元
那么再往后的话就是说
诶如果我希望这个数据和我的这个这个处理
形成一个闭包
那形成一个整个打包在一起的体验
就类似于像我们高级语言的类这个概念
那其实呢这就是这个在大家如果学习这个
就是像unreal的这样的一员的时候
它的一个blue print其实非常就像一个类
而且你会发现到blueprint里面会定义很多诶
只属于local variable对吧
就是我这个类自己用的viable ui web
我可以变成private
我只能自己看到
有些val变成别人看到
所以其实比如说我举个例子
比如像虚幻引擎
是一个非常深受C加思想影响的这么个引擎
其实我们去看他的blue print
这个体系结构的设计啊
就非常像把C加的一些概念用
这个就是说脚本化的
用这个图形化的方法把它表达出来了
所以你一旦有这样的一个基础之后
理解它的难度就并不大了
那么所以这里面就点出了这个
当然了
他有很多这种辅助性的设置
就比如说哎你移上去
给你进行一种非常快速的帮你测试这些节点
包括当你的一个点拖出来之后
他直接给你提示
这一点
我个人觉得是unreal做的非常好的东西
如果大家在做自己引擎的这个系统的时候
如果你做完基础的功能
你再做一些这些功能的话
我认为是非常有必要的
因为它会极大的提高你的使用者的效率
就是我们一直讲引擎是什么吗
很多人很多很多人认为引擎是一些高深的算法
但是呢我们自己做引擎的
这个这个行业从业者的话
我们会认为引擎的本质它是生产力工具
就一个引擎的好坏不是由你多少种功能决定的
而是由什么呢
由别人用起来的效率决定的
其实这一点你就是如何做一个让别人用起来
效率很高的引擎
这件事情是门槛非常高的一件事情
真的他这里面有很多很多事情
需要我们学习和努力的
所以那你有了这样的一个scripting的话
那接下来的话其实很重要的一个东西
就是说你要去debug debug起来
其实他就因为你把整个逻辑全部变成
可视化之后
当我的任何一个对象在什么状态的时候
那个节点就会被highlight
然后呢你鼠标一上去
它会告诉你各种web
我们程序员也非常习惯于第八个
对不对
我们是习惯于什么呢
加一个断点
在那个时候通过print数值
我能看到他所有的东西
但是大家想想看
对于艺术家来讲
对于这个设计师来讲
这件事情是很难
那么唉你一旦变成了这个可视化的语言的时候
它就变得非常的简单了
很直觉我确实观察过
就是说艺术家他怎么去用这个这个
这个就是说不UI这样的系统的时候
我会发现确实虽然作为程序员来讲
我们会觉得BLUPRINT系统特别的麻烦对吧
没有写代码写的那么舒服
但是对于一个没有编程基础的人
他真的符合他所有的直觉
包括第八个这个过程好
那么其实可视化编程系统呢
它也不是就是特别好啊
就是没有问题的
事实上我们在工程实践中发现
这个东西问题也是挺多的
比如说对于一个大型游戏产品来讲的话
如果这个脚本或者这个这个可视化脚本
不是一个人去改的话
那么几个人同时改的时候
他们之间的merge就会变成一个很痛苦的问题
因为如果是代码之间
merge其实是比较简单的
大家如果写过这种
比如说一些beond compare这些软件的时候
你用过的话
你就知道还是挺方便的对吧
但是而且你很容易理解
就是说这一行代码加上去语义的变化
但是对于一个图来讲的话
这个节点添加删除
包括移动之后
他们之间的merge
实际上就算你可以merge
默认出他的语音已经没有一个人能讲的清楚了
这也是我们在跟很多就是啊
做国内大型商业产品的团队去交流的时候
你会发现一个很有意思的特点
就是说大家在用虚幻引擎
就这种就是我们只是举个例子啊
就是用这种有可视化编程的
这种语言的那个引擎的时候
他做PTAP阶段
用这种啊visual scripting系统非常的快
能快速put type
但是他一旦进入了产业化生产的时候
他们的这个工程师一定会把它变成
就是要么用C加代码原生态去写
要么就用其他的脚本语言替代掉
这样的话方便他们进行管理
进行merge
但是还有一个考虑
就是说那个早期的VIUI语言执行效率比较低
他们希望用更快的语言去写
这样效率更高一点
但这其实呢也反映出了就是威尔斯克T系统
它的本身的一个问题
那么另外一个的话就是risk
UI系统的一个比较大的问题
就是代码它是线性的
你可以依次读下对吧
我们这么多年的眼镜的话呢
就是说A代码它的就是分块性
比如说函数的定义类的定义
分成不同的文件上下文
你能看得非常的清楚清晰易读
但是当你面对一个真正的商业级游戏的
这个这个这个这个就是说reception的结果的话
他真的有的时候就像一团乱麻一样的
那么除非创作者就是写这个脚本的人
自己就画这个的人
自己他是知道怎么回事
很多时候比如别人接手的时候
是一下子根本看不清楚是怎么去用的
所以这也是这个就是可视化脚本的
一个很很很难的一个问题
所以说它是一个非常好的
给这个设计师和艺术家做put type的工具
但是你真的到工业化应用的时候
它还是要用很多方法把它变成一个可规范的
可追踪的
而且可第八个的这么一个东西
那么讲到这儿的话呢
其实我觉得就是威尔UI系统的话
大家仔细看
其实他并没有大家想象的那么神秘和复杂
但是呢它到底和脚本什么关系
其实这里面我想大家只要记住一个概念就好了
实际上啊
VIOUI系统和脚本就是一模一样的东西
大家想象一下
就今天我们看到了一个
比如说一个比如像unreal的蓝图
或者是unity rescripting
你可以直接把它编译成一个LUA脚本
你可以把获了一个c#的脚本
就大家可以完全先写一个脚
你自己的脚本系统
然后呢
你再去做一个
你的这个就是可图形化的这个逻辑系统
然后呢其实你只要做一件事情
就是把你的这个图形化的逻辑
这个这个这个就是vo graph的这个东西
把它就是渲染成一个脚本的代码
然后呢你前面所有的逻辑都不用动
那这两个东西就可以直接去执行
当然现在的这个就是很多的引擎
它不再去走脚本这一步了
他直接把图编程这个机器码变成bad code
这样效率会更高一点
但是如果你想增加这中间的第八个
第八个ability
甚至少写一些代码的话呢
其实你可以把一个图编译成一个脚本
然后再用脚本编译成机器码再去执行它
其实效果是完全一模一样的
所以这个呢实际上就是这个visual graph的本质
它本质上其实就是一种可视化的脚本
所以同学们讲到这1part的话
大家就知道了
就现代引擎最引以为傲的可视化编程系统
它的底层是这个问题
但这东西讲起来非常简单
入门你你去理解它的基本概念也很简单
但是呢大家如果真的去做它
包括把里面很多的小细节处理完的话
其实它的复杂度蛮高的
比如刚才我讲的一件事
你就说诶我在我这个可视化的系统里面
我可以定义各种各样的新的event
扩展各种各样游戏的功能
我还可以兼容其他的一些脚本
一些额外的功能
那这个就要求你系统做的非常的复杂了
所以说就像我刚才讲的是
你实现一个简单的可视化编程系统啊
我觉得大家做几个月应该能做得出来
就一个人做
做几个月是真的能做出来的
但是呢你想做一个商业级可用的
那可能是一群人干个一两年是很正常的
那你比如说像荣耀的blue print
已经迭代了这么多年了
那现在他们还在快速的演进中
这里面其实我们自己去分析的话
就会发现这里面有很多很有意思的东西可以带
值得大家去去理解和学习
基本上讲到这儿
我们的游戏逻辑的核心基本上就讲完了
那为什么讲到这儿就不讲了呢
因为很简单
就是再往下讲
就是太碎太杂了
就是已经基本上怎么说呢
就是今天我讲了
你真的要做个game engineer的话
你其实要掌握的东西还是蛮多的
很多很细碎的东西
那所以最后呢我们在这一趴
因为今天这节课内容比较多啊
我们就讲一个比较简单的东西吧
就是叫3C系统
因为这也是游戏玩法里面大名鼎鼎的
就很心动
那首先呢在讲这1part之前呢
哦我就像一个我一个很认可的一个游戏
去致敬嘛
就是这个意思
takes two对吧
双人成行
因为我觉得如果大家去理解
什么叫3C系统的话
我觉得双人成行是一个最好的案例
可以说做的非常的极致
很多时候我觉得他比很多3A大作做的都到位
那么就是什么叫一个3C系统呢
简单来讲就是角色控制和相机
那么它基本上是最重要的
这个element对于我们的游游戏的体验
就是玩家对游戏世界的感知
其实就是通过角色
然后你通过控制这个角色
然后你怎么看到这个角色感知的角色
你是通过相机的
所以这三个东西形成了我们游戏的
很多体验的核心
它不是所有玩法的核心
玩法有很多东西对吧
那么但是的话呢
就是说这个体验的最直接的体验
是来自于这个3C系统
那首先讲角色
角色大家会觉得哦是不是讲角色的模型
角色动画其实不是的
就角色它是讲什么呢
就是讲这个角色的移动
你怎么让他动起来
你怎么让角色战斗起来对吧
包括就是他的这个各种各样的
就是A他的healthy啊
他的放出魔法的各种技能这种体系啊
那么这些东西
这些feedback系统对你对游戏的感知是最直接的
这个影响
那么举个最简单的例子
就是最容易大家忽略的就是它的移动哎
这里面举个例子就是我们举一个巫师的例子
大家看到就是说
如果大家还记得我们在讲小引擎的时候对吧
移动诶它无非就是向前走
向左走
向右走
然后呢也有一个加速
有个减速
对不对
但是如果真的我们去看一个
就是啊3A游戏的一个角色移动的时候
你会发现它的细节非常的多
因为在很多时候你会碰到障碍物
你会上坡
你会下坡
你会这个时候走着突然就停了
然后呢你会穿穿过一道门或者怎么样
你会面前有个小坎儿
这时候角色的移动就会有很多
很多的细节需要你去响应
因为你如果不这样做的话
这个角色你看起来就很僵
因为没有人喜欢玩一个游戏
整个角色就很像robot一样
就这样永远这样走
然后的话看见山也是这样走
看见这个平地也是这么走
那你的感觉就很奇怪
所以说角色的移动实际上对于好的游戏来讲
有无数的细节
那么另外一个的话呢就是说其实角色的话呢
它实际上是要和游戏世界里的各种环境
各种物体进行互动的
比如说诶我走着走着
我突然抓一个东西吊起来对吧
比如说我走着走着
我走到一个冰面上
诶我是时候开始变成滑冰的这个效果了
那这个动作是不是整个就完全变掉了
对不对
那还有比如说我跳到水里面了对吧
我的行为又会不一样
所以其实角色的这个就角色的这个运动的话
实际上是非常非常复杂的
那么另外一个的话呢
就是说角色的话呢它和环境各种互动
比如说你要和你的这个terrain系统
你地面上是一个沙地对吧
你还是个雪地
那么还有就是说我在不同的环境下
我要产生各种各样的音效
各种各样的这个这个particle效果
实际上都是要角色系统跟这个环境产生了互动
那么另外一个的话呢就是说其实角色的移动呢
很多时候它和物理系统系关系
比如说当我去滑翔的时候对吧
我要去模拟空气的flow
所以这个时候我既要有我的控制
又要有物理的输出
所以真实的在游戏中的一个角色系统的话
怎么去做呢
一般来讲我们都是用状态机的方法去做
那这里面随便举个例子
这里面这个这个例子不算复杂
这不是个3A游戏的一个结果
这是unity的一个案例
但这个其实都已经算是很简单的
一个角色系统的一个控制
实际上在我们就大家还记得
我在讲动画系统的时候讲过
就是说现代动画系统
比如动画树的这个这个设计
它有个叫AISM动画状态机
对不对
其实动画状态机里面你点进去
你会发现它每一个节点
它又可以是一段脚本系统
这就是说
当我在各种各样的动画之间去切换的时候
实际上它上面还挂载很多很复杂的业务逻辑
所以说当我们再去写一个游戏的时候
一个好的游戏啊
它的character系统实际上是用大量的动画的
这个这个这个script或者是graph
在内嵌了大量的逻辑的script tograph
形成了这样一个综合的结果
所以我们在做引擎的时候
我们怎么去想这个问题呢
其实做引擎很多时候我们也做不了太多的事情
我们可以做物理系统对吧
我们可以做动画系统
我们也可以做这个脚本系统
但是呢最核心的是说
我们在设计的时候
要允许这些系统互相之间的状态
都可以互相通讯
然后呢这个通讯具体发生什么
逻辑的话
我们要把它开放给我们的设计师
让他们来定义
这个时候它才能产生一个我们想要的
这样一个丰富的角色行为系统
其实后面讲的这个就是说control和camera也是一个道理
那么control是核心是什么呢
就是哎最简单的第一条
就是他要处理各种各样的输入设备
大家可能有时候意识不到
就是在游戏里面
这个行业里面
我们遇遇到的输入设备是很多很多的
比如说可能是这个方向盘
手柄对吧
鼠标键盘对不对
各种各样奇怪的
还有那个你那个飞行控制模拟器的这些东西
那么你各种各样的
这个包括那个做VR的时候手势
其实这些输入和游戏并不是直接关联的
而control系统就是要把这种输入设备的input
变成我们真正的game play的这个device
就变成我们游戏的game play
而且不同的game play你的感受还不一样
所以control系统就干这个事儿
听上去是不是很简单诶
但是其实你真的做到一个好的CTRL系统
它的细节特别多
这里面就举这个例子
就比如说我射钉子这个例子对吧
这个例子很多同学应该有感觉诶
做的真的是很舒服
那为什么你会觉得这个操作就那么的舒服呢
难道他用的鼠标对吧
用的手柄已经跟我们不一样吗
肯定是一样的
对不对
不同的游戏用的都是一样的手柄
一样的鼠键盘鼠标
但为什么他做的让你感觉好
这里面讲几个细节啊
比如说哎当你去鼠标右键按下去
我要瞄准诶
开始移动它
左键按下去
我要输出的时候
它是上在前面的一定系统讲的时候
我会产生一个AAI和shoot的这样的event
对不对
然后我的行行为就发生变化了
这个听上去很简单的
但实际上这里面的细节就在魔鬼
那魔鬼就在这个细节里面
那么当我们去一按这个瞄准的时候
其实这个时候我的状态就变掉了
就这个时候我的相机就会UI就会说诶
把这个更加聚焦
大家记得我们在讲render的时候
怎么去做这个望远镜的效果
就是把FA变小
而且相机的位置也会发生变化
这个时候我们就会更加的聚焦
看我们标点好
当我们的鼠标开始去移动寻找的目标点的时候
实际上大家注意到没有
它其实有一个小小的吸附的效果
这个吸附效果大家千万不要小瞧它
其实这个地方我们在引擎这一侧是要开放一个
就是说编辑系统交给设计师和艺术家去编辑的
这个时候
当你的这个curse移移动到你的目标点的时候
首先我要的定义哪些东西是我的目标
然后我要能判断说我的脚本系统
能判断说我和他之间的夹角小于多少度的时候
我就触发这种吸附系统
而且这个吸附不是一瞬间的
它上市也有一个过程过去了
其实这件事情对你游戏的手感
影响是非常非常大的
给大家举个例子啊
比如说嗯嗯射击游戏
其实大部分的在主机上的射击游戏
都会带或多或少的吸附系统
这就是为什么你在主机上玩一些
做的不是特别好的设计游戏的
你的感觉就是我很难瞄中人
为什么呢
如果我完全依据你手柄的输入去移动你的鼠标
左右移动的时候
你那时候玩起来其实是很难受的
你基本上套路中的
你很多时候你觉得你要套住这个人的时候
你会发现这个角色你你那curse就划过去了
为什么呢
因为你眼睛看到那个东西和你反映到你的手上
然后呢再到这个手柄传输到那个主机
主机再去处理
这个中间的latency可以达到将近一两百毫秒
这个数据是大家很敬业的
大家没有想到这个延迟有这么大
所以因因为那个东西移动它是有惯性的嘛
所以很多时候如果不做吸附处理的话
你是基本上套不中任何一个人的
更不要说我去枪枪狙瞄苗头了
而这种AI assistant这个系统的话就是CTRL系统
一个非常核心的一个设计
而这个系统的话就需要我们在前面工具也好
包括我们的脚本也好
都要提供相应的数据编辑功能
教给我们的艺术家
那么另外一个的话呢就是反馈
那反馈的话就这里面的话
比如像双人成行里面那个剧的感觉
对不对
大家觉得太想去了
它实际上通过什么呢
诶通过让你的手柄有那种震动感
当然这里面我们要小小的提示一下
那些用鼠标键盘的同学
你们是感受不到那种快乐的对吧
那么中反馈只有手柄有吗
其实没有诶
比如说那个我们的那个就是
如果你把那个模拟飞行
你用那个飞行手柄
其实手柄很多好
高级手柄是有力反馈的
比如说你要玩那个赛车游戏
你插入的是那个高级的
这个赛车的键盘和整个座套
其实那个很多那个车车的方向盘
有的游戏是有力反馈的
就感觉非常好
所以其实control的一个很核心的点
就是给你的反馈感诶
我这边反过来问大家一个问题
那如果我就是鼠标键盘
那我有没有反馈可以做呢
大家想想有没有
其实这里面是有的
有是什么东西呢
哎就是大名鼎鼎的RGB啊
大家是买一些就是游戏本的时候
你发现有一个特点
就是说当你打到游戏紧张的时候
那个游戏键盘或者是个那个那个游戏本身
那个背光就会发生变化
对不对
当你残血的时候
突然变成了一片血红之色
就什么东西
只要上了RGB就变得很高级了
是的
其实在实在没有办法做力反馈的情况下
其实有些游戏都用最新最简单的光效
也让你觉得有一点点那么的这个代入感
所以反馈对于control来讲非常重要
其实我一直在讲游戏和电影行业最大的区别
这也是同学们的喜欢做游戏引擎啊
我想讲的一件事
就是为什么我这么热爱做游戏引擎
就是说我一直觉得就是做电影艺术
也是个视觉艺术对吧
但是呢他是个我叫做被动媒体
叫papal media
什么意思
就是说我做了
你们也不要给我有任何的这个反馈
你们就看吧
我做啥你看什么呀
但游戏的特点是什么
就是根据用户的输入
我会跟他有各种互动和反馈
所以游戏是一个proactive
是一个主动媒体
就是说它最核心的精髓
就在于游戏世界和我的行为之间的互动
所以control呢就是解决了这个互动最核心的一个
一个一个系统
所以control系统其实本身并不简单
那么他真的我们要去做这样的CTRL系统的话
实际上它还要区分
比如说你在不同的环境下对吧
同样一个案件
它可能产生的操作是完全完全不一样的
那这个地方设计又是
你觉得我们程序员能控制吗
程序员肯定控制不了
对不对
那怎么办
我们只能在引擎里面提供这样的一个接口
让设计师让艺术家可以去定义它
通过什么定义呢
通过刚才前面讲的visual scripting
通过那个脚本系统来定义他
各种各样不同的行为
所以在这里面的话呢
就是我们去定义用户的输入的时候
它其实一定是多肽的
其实很多用户的输入它可以是组合键
对吧
叫CORE
也可以是一串按键
大家以前如果玩过街霸的话
就应该知道那个按键的那个序列
那可是我们反复苦练的东西
对不对
所以所以说其实这也是control系统
一个很核心的一个东西
所以其实呢就是说呃哦所以说control系统的话呢
其实我一直认为就是很多时候会被大家低估
大家都觉得做过游戏
是不是就鼠标键盘按下什么键
我就做个什么东西
其实不是的
如果这样直接的翻译
它不是不会上升到一个系统
但是如果你真的做到一个3A游戏
那种感觉的东西的话
其实control系统反而是你丝滑手感的由来
它它实际上是真的决定了你整个游戏的手感
包括刚才我讲的feedback对吧
那么现代游戏的设备会越来越注重于
就是反向对用户的多生态的这种反馈
比如说像那个像PS5的手柄上还带了个小喇叭
我经常玩恐怖游戏的时候
玩着玩着突然小喇叭就想起来了
把我吓了一跳
哼然后而且那个小喇叭上还有麦克风
经常一不小心突然发现那边有一个
就是那个其他的玩家在跟你说话
然后你然后你又很想跟他说话
所以这种感觉
其实这种control系统是蛮有意思的一个东西
好啊
最后今天也是最后一个系统
就是我们的camera系统了
其实相机系统大家会觉得我们讲了rendering
相机系统不就有了嘛
对不对
不就是这个相机系统想起来非常的简单
就是说哎你设定一个相机的位置叫POV对吧
然后再设定一个FOV相机的张角
我的一个相机系统就有了
是的它就是这么简单
但是呢
其实相机很多时候是要和你的角色绑在一起的
但是大家如果仔细观察
一个有好的游戏的相机啊
你观察它并不是固定死在你身体后面的
某一个固定长度
只是由你的视角决定了
实际上一个是当你角色在跑动走动
这个相机的距离远近都会发生变化
而这个才是相机系统一个很精妙的东西
那么其实在相机系统的话呢
有个很著名的东西叫弹簧臂
大家可能也听说过
就是说当我这个左右动的时候
如果是第三人称视角的游戏的话
我会保证我的相机尽量不要穿墙
但是很多游戏做不到对吧
今天我有这样的bug
其实这个东西大家也会知道
处理起来还是挺麻烦的
因为各种各样的情况都要
有的时候是你不能穿墙
有的时候呢你还可以穿墙
但是把那个墙要透明度
这里面有很多的小细节在处理
那么包括呢就是当你进入focus模式的时候
诶这个相机要变得更加聚焦一点
这都是我们经常很熟悉的东西
但其实呢就是相机真正有意思的东西是什么呢
就是说呃当我在不同的速度
在我不同的游戏模式下
当我看到不同方向的时候
它相机的远近大小都要发生变化
这个时候呢其实有一个很著名的东西
叫做camera cage
什么意思
就是说或者叫camera track
就是设计师会设计我这个角色在什么状态下
我的相机的参数
包括它的位置都要精心的定义过
他最后在空间上可视化出来
就像一个很奇怪的形状的一个一个笼子
那为什么这东西这么重要
因为相机啊
实际上在游戏里面
表达的是一种非常强的人的主观感受
你你的眼睛瞳孔是会放缩的
比如说我们恐惧的时候对吧
瞳孔会放大
然后呢你看的东西会更
其实你的FV会变缩小
你会更聚焦在你眼前的敌人
当你在放松的时候
你的瞳孔会A会缩小
你看的地方会更更宽泛
然后那个时候的话呢
你可能就会看的面更广一点
让很多周围的事情你能看得到对吧
当然还有各种各样的状态
所以所以相机
它其实是一种非常非常强的主观感受
而所谓的相机系统的话
就是让设计师有能力
精准的去表达人的主体感受
因为实际上我们在打游戏的时候
我并不是真的在那个游戏世界里面对吧
但是的话呢我隔着那个屏幕也能感受到
如同身临其境的紧张感或者代入感
所以这就是相机系统很核心的一个
一个解决的问题
那么其实相机系统的话呢
它还会触发很多的相机的效果
比如最著名的抖屏
其实大家我们在讲经常游戏讲叫打击感吗
打击感其实这里面用到了很多相机系统的技术
比如说屏幕的震动对吧
打到一下屏幕的震动
比如说我打了一下屏幕
突然就全屏的那种诶一下子白掉了
或者一下子黑掉的这种效果
那这种或者camera effect这种效果
其实这也是相机系统很核心的一个啊
功能要开放给我们的设计师
那还有卡相机桶是什么呢
就是说哎其实在真实的游戏里面
它有很多很多的相机
但是呢每一次你你以为你只能看到一个相机
其实它会在很多的相机之间来回切换
比如说举个例子啊
比如说啊一款设计游戏
当我端起枪的时候
我进入了FPS模式对吧
那个时候哎我就看到了一个FPS
我看不到我
其实我那个相机是用了一个
那个就是说一个FS第一认真设计的游戏
但这个时候我把枪装起来
然后呢我这个角色开始走的时候
有的游戏他就会切回到第三人称诶
当我在地上捡到了一颗加特林重机枪
我把重机枪拎在手上的时候
诶你看发现那个相机的位置又发生了变化
它当你拎着向左看右看的时候
它的相机视角又会发生变化
其实在这么一个简单的过程中
已经切换了三次套相机了
比如说我急喷的时候
又是一条相机
比如说我开车对吧
我我端起把枪
我开始狙击镜的时候
我的相机就变掉了
当我进入了一辆赛车里面
诶
我的相机位置和它的逻辑又会发生变化
所以其实在真实的游戏里面的话
你会发现你有很多很多的相机
根据你游戏不同的状态
而且呢所谓的他就需要一个camera system
就camera manager去管理它
而且呢kai major还有一个很重要的任务
就是什么呢
在这些相机里面来回的让你去实现它的差值
所以一个camera的话
实际上比大家想象的要复杂得多
那么这个camera system的话呢
其实它要解决的一个非常重要的一个东西
就是这个我们叫subjective feeling
就是说主观感受
比如说像这里面你要去表达一个滑道的时候
其实我那个时候通过我的motion blur对吧
就是那个运动模糊
通过相机的这种抖动抖动
包括他的视视野的放缩
就给你形成一种非常强的
身临其境的这样的一种代入感
速度感和代入感
而这件事情的话
其实都是相机系统设计所实现的
那另外一个的话呢
就是说比如说我们去表达一个角色
在跑动的时候
其实相机并不是机械的绑在角色身上
它实际上相机会有自己的惯性
自己的逻辑
这样你会觉得这个角色的运动感觉是活的
如果相机只是机械地绑在角色身上
你不会觉得相机死
你会觉得那个角色很僵
包括相机
有的时候也会负责产生一种电影般的画面
所以说其实相机呢其实对于游戏的这种表现力
的影响是非常非常大的
所以说我我记得我在讲render时候讲过
就是说哎后处理的look up table
这个方法是一个性价比很高的系统
让你游戏一下子上档次
对不对
那这里面我们在讲游戏玩法系统的时候
我要跟大家讲的就是说camera系统
其实是我认为一个性价比非常高的
让你的游戏有这种大作感的这样的一个系统
那其实呢就是说camera系统
那刚才讲的那些细节
大家听到更像是讲游戏设计
对不对
是的
我讲了很多游戏设计的东西
但是呢作为游戏引擎来讲的话
我们在设计camera系统的时候
就要考虑到就是说我们的任何一款游戏产品
它可能有很多的相机
而且我在定义相机行为的时候呢
它实际上是有很多的功能的对吧
各种各样的状态
我要读取角色的速度
我要去调用各种各样的camera的效果
我要调整相机的FOV
我要是相机抖动起来
那么这些所有的功能呢要允许用一个脚本系统
或者是一个very good scripting
就是说可视化的这样的一个
比如像BLUPRINT这样的一个可视化的图
图形编程系统
能对这个相机的行为进行编辑
那你引擎测必须要提供这样的一个camera
系统的功能的话
别人才能在你上面开发一个高质量的游戏
所以这也是引擎对于相机系统的一个
重要的一个支撑吧
所以这就是大家去理解什么叫3C
这样大家听我讲完之后是不会意识到诶
其实3C为什么对现代游戏这么重要
而且现代游戏引擎也是一个非常重要的一个啊
要支撑这个复杂的散热系统
才能决定我们游戏产出的质量
现在大家就只能理解这里面的很多
很有趣的妙处了
其实很多同学听完我们这门课呢
并不一定会做游戏引擎
比如说你们是做游戏的
但是呢大家听了这些东西之后
再结合引擎开放的功能就能理解哦
如何做一个操作感体验感很强的一个游戏好
所以呢讲到这一趴
基本上game play基本上讲完了
就是所以其实我在准备这节课的时候哈
其实我记得是昨天下午的时候
我跟我们课程的小伙伴们有个对话
我我在说我准备完这门课
我觉得好像我也没有讲什么高深的东西
像我们之前很多课都有很多很高端的
这种高屋建瓴的提炼对吧
好像跟play系统讲的都是一些很工程实践的东西
很很很简单
好像每个东西都不是很难
我说game play系统
玩法系统到底它的本质是什么东西
然后我们课程的小伙伴大家讨论了半天
最后的结论是什么呢
就是说其实game play真的就是一个everything
就是游戏玩法的几乎所有东西都是game play系统
它确实就是一个很难被定义边界的
这么一个系统
它不像物理
不像这个rendering对吧
它的边界特别的清楚
game boy系统它的边界其实并不清楚
那么其实我们整个行业总结了这么多年
好像也就提炼了这么些东西
比如说我们要用event系统对吧
用这个模式去统一游戏内机构之间的communication
这样的话让这些肯定开始变得更加有序可管理
那我们知道很多逻辑
我没有办法在引擎里把他写死
那怎么办
我只能开放出这个scraping的系统
让大家去让设计师也好
让艺术家好
可以定制这个游戏各种各样的玩法
那么那screaming系统又太难学了
怎么办
那我们就用VSCOT系统对吧
让大家更加方便地掌握这些
各种各样玩法的开放
但是今天我真的要做一个SG
我真的要做个卡牌游戏
我真的要做一个PS游戏
我真的要做一个RTS游戏
实际上它的game play差别还是非常非常大的
他的很多上层代码
包括引擎有些东西都要被改
所以这也是就是大家在这个理解玩法
系统的时候
要有这个敬畏之心
就这里面的话
至少以我的经验和浅见的话
我很难找到一个叫做一招鲜
就是一个架构
能够把所有的游戏全部都能够cover住的
这么的一个一个系统
所以的话呢基本上每一个优秀的作品
他在跟play系统上都会有自己的一些想法和突破
所以的话呢这也是为什么
游戏引擎其实很多时候啊并不能够是万能啊
大家很多人会认为我能不能做一游戏引擎
支持所有的游戏
理论上可不可以可以的
但是在现代实践中
你会发现就是很多不同类型的游戏
他会有自己的引擎的preference
也是这个道理也在这个地方
所以的话呢这也是就是GAI系统
它非常美妙
非常值得大家去思考的一个东西
好的
以上呢就是我今天关于玩法系统的第一节课
帮助大家建立我game play系统的一个基础的概念
好那今天的课程我们先讲到这部分
那就是那个再次感谢一下
我们的课程组的小伙伴
就是同志们还是非常的辛苦
就是哈
这个虽然说我们上一节课到现在有两周时间啊
但是这两周基本上大家都没休息
都在这个
我到昨天前天全部都在加班
然后我们就在这大家一起弄
然后今天我大概是最后到五点才
把今天的课程全部准备完成
所以的话呢就是希望能够帮助到同学们
那接下来又到了我们传统时间
就是大家有没有什么问题
关于游戏玩法系统
好好的
第一个问题
同学问我说接入了可视化脚本之后
是不是就不需要用传统脚本了啊
原则上来讲确实是可以这么干的
但是呢实际上游戏的开发者很少会这么做
其实我们看到很多工程实践中的话
可视化脚本的话呢
大家会作为早期的PTAP
特别是开放给艺术家
开放给设计师用
但是的话呢脚本一般大家都会留
其实你们看到比如举个例子吧
这个可视化脚本做的最好的是虚幻引擎对吧
但是很多虚幻用虚幻引擎的团队
一定会再开发一套自己的脚本系统
作为自己的开发的需要
所以其实可视化脚本和脚本之间呢
它不是一个替代关系
就是在有些时候脚本写起来效率更高
而且更好维护
在有些时候呢可视化脚本就够用了对吧
而且我可以方便很多其他人都用起来
所以这两个在引擎实践中的话
我会觉得就是说如果你想支持一个可视化脚本
我都会非常建议第一步
你先把脚脚本系统给支持了
我你有了脚本系统的知识
你再去支持可视化脚本
然后呢你有了可视化脚本之后
也不要这个喜新厌旧
我建议两套系统都要保留啊
哇这个问题好难啊
有同学问我说
未来平台是不是趋向于禁止热更啊
这个实际上是很专业了
其实在传统的比如说PC游戏的时候
那真是个快乐的时代
就是我们会非常方便的热跟所有的游戏
特别是对于大家经常玩的
比如像魔兽世界啊
像那种大型的MRPG
它没有热根
基本上这个游戏是没法运行的
因为这种复杂产品它一定会有很多的问题
大家想象不到的
但是呢我们也看到
就在现在的一些平台上举个例子啊
比如说像控制的比较严的IOS平台
就是我们想像手机上的移动端平台对吧
IOS平台
那他为了防止呢
你就是在他的这个一审核完的游戏内容后
又在注入一些他不受审核的新内容
他就不是不想让你去热根
所以这个时候其实很多开发者
特别是做这种online game的开发者就非常痛苦
那么包括像做主机游戏
举个例子
Plain xbox
我记得我们花了很久时间
试图跟这些爸爸们沟通
说其实如果我们做个online gaming是非常需要热更的
但是呢他平台有很多安全性的问题
举个例子
比如说PLAYSTATION他的那个那个你看到的游戏
它是被加密过的
那这个加密过程呢不受我们控制
只受平台来控制
那这个时候热更起来就很麻烦
所以啊我不认为
就是未来的游戏平台都一定会禁止热更
这件事情
实际上是对开发者来讲
是非常不方便的一件事情
但确实现在有很多平台真的不让我们热梗
但是未来到底大家是越来越封闭
说OK大家都不知干了对吧
还是说大家都明白了
没有热根
那我对一个超复杂的游戏是没法做的情况下
大家都慢慢的想一个方法打开你授权去做
我觉得这是两种可能发生的未来
但我作为一个游戏开发者
作为一个引擎开发者的话呢
那我肯定是希望平台将来要开放
越来越方便的热梗了
因为热根对于游戏来讲真的非常的重要
哇这个问题好难啊
这个这个问题是有点难
同学问我说
就是有可能采取逻辑和表现分离的方法
开发游戏吗
实际上在游戏开发中
大部分时候逻辑和表现是分离的
特别是它其实取决于你的游戏的类型
比如说啊像传统的MRPG游戏
比如说哎我们这种呃
大家知道那种修仙练级打怪这种游戏
那么他的表现其实相对来讲比较简单
就是说我的各种技能啊打出去对吧
要打出多少伤害结算
那其实很多时候
游戏的逻辑就可以由我们设计师团队单独去写
然后呢产生各种各样复杂的业务结算
那么其实它的表现那一块和逻辑这块
分的是非常非常开的
那么包括就是有的时候
我觉得他的策策划
就像跟那个我们的艺术家下订单一样的说
我要这几个特效
每个特效打多远对吧好
这个依次从低级到高级怎么样
然后他去配数值
他去配结算
配各种音质的东西
然后呢相应的这些数据配好了之后
下面的表现直接调用
你就能产生你的效果
这样它的玩法开发效率是非常非常高的
所以在这样的类型的游戏里面的话
逻辑和表现分的还是挺开的
而且这是有的时候团队规模可以做的很大
一般来讲在产品研发中的话
我们认为就是如果组织里面的这种啊
就不同工种的同学
这个分离的越快
就decoupling越好的话
它的开发效率就越好
确实这种游戏里面这种效率是很高的
但是对于现代游戏来讲
大家现在玩游戏
很少有人在玩
喜欢玩那种纯素质的游戏了对吧
大家要求的是打造打击感动作的表现
整个角色和环境的互动越来越多的这种细节
特别像3A游戏这种游戏
那这个时候的话呢
其实你会发现
这个逻辑和表现之间的关系就会越来越密切
因为你会发现
就是说对于现代游戏玩家来讲的话
他会越来越讲究
就是他不再是简单的说哎我递上一个装备
啪就到我背包里面
背包那个旁边那个背包里面出现了一个装备
你希望看到这个人攻下身来捡起这个东西
捡起东西看两眼
嗯不错
然后呢要放到我的包里面对吧
然后这个东西它如果有发光
有什么东西的时候
我身上还有一些效果会出来
然后呢这个角色身上背的这个东西有点重
我走路的姿态好像发生了一些变化
但我这讲的有点夸张了
但实际上对于现代游戏发展来讲的话
我们的用户其实对于这种这个这个角色的
细节的要求已经是越来越高了
这个时候呢客观上就要求引擎
它能越来越方便的
让我们不同工那个工种的同学
就设计师也好
艺术家也好
包括程序也好
能够合力在一起
去把一个玩法和他的这个表现糅合在一起去做
那这里面的话呢其实无论对游戏开发团队
对引擎来讲都提出了更高的要求
所以我个人觉得的话呢
就是在未来的这种类型的游戏里面
特别是大家如果做主机游戏的话
那基本上来讲的话
游戏玩法和表现比较难以分开
这是我自己个人的一个实践
如果有更好的架构能分开
我觉得我会非常乐意尝试
因为这样的效率会更高嘛
但是在实操中的话
就像刚才我讲3C系统一样的话
其实他的表现和玩法其实高度相关
因为3C不仅仅只是表现
他实际上跟玩法也很有关系
对所以的话那个这个的话呢是现在开发中的话
大家一定要注意
包括引擎架构的时候也要注意的
就是我建议是保持这种开放性
就像刚才第一个问题
同学跟我说
脚本和可视化的脚本
两个是不是那个可以彻底的
这个这个这个一个是替代一个的关系
我个人觉得是有点难
他两个都有作用
其实大家如果理解现代游戏引擎啊
他就明白
它并不是一个大家想象中一个完美的理想架构
它实际上是一个呃大量的妥协
然后呢保持了各种可能性的一个工程基础平台
然后根据某种各种类型的游戏
你可以去选取其中的一些模块去强化
去表现你游戏的内容对
所以这个问题我的答案是这样的
好的
今天好像一下子又讲了将近两个小时
那我们今天要不先到这样
那再次谢谢同学们
然后呢就是休息了两个星期
我感觉我也回血回的非常多了
然后呢下个星期我们同学们再见面
那个时候我跟同学讲什么呢
就会讲特别可爱的
特别有趣的AI系统
那我们下周见
谢谢大家好
拜拜